Stream, Snape, Shavey and I, because I have good English.
I'm ready when you are, no longer saying anything offensive.
That's not always too cool.
That'll never stop me.
Can't stop me. Ignorance.
Oh wait, I think it's funny because my stream has been started so this will probably show up.
Right, okay, I'm live too.
I'm live.
It takes like 30 seconds for it to register.
So I would say hi to Vod.
I don't know what's happening.
It's like, it's not letting me type in my own chat.
You've done it now.
Am I banned from my own chat?
Let me go look at your chat as well.
I graduated live.
This is if we're doing it.
Imagine a company did that.
They're just like, hey, I'm going to have you collide with everybody and then like a manager and like a PNG shows up and they're like, I'm sorry, you're gone.
That has to have happened behind the scenes.
And like that feature has just been too polite to say anything about what happened.
I got signed on my YouTube channel.
I can't fucking comment on your stream.
What?
Wait.
Oh my god.
I got signed on my YouTube channel.
I can't pin my fucking...
Is that what happened?
Did I get sent out of my YouTube?
Hold on a minute.
I'm trying to be a lawyer.
Hold on.
I can't just hit the...
I can't hit the YouTube.
I suck at it.
I was like, I was...
This is the kind of type of jokes we're making all day of day.
No.
She started it.
I woke up and the first thing she sends me is a freaking Skippity 9-11 meme.
I'm like, fuck's sake.
What am I supposed to do with that?
Wait, it's me.
Hold on.
I'm still...
It says error try again.
Hold on.
I'm getting your YouTube.
Help.
I'm getting your YouTube password.
I can't talk away on chat.
I'm sorry.
We're just...
No, don't add me yet.
I'm not even putting that last fucking stream in the game.
I'm not putting down my stream name yet.
Stop.
Am I live?
I'm live.
Yeah, you're live.
I'm also live.
I'm getting your YouTube password.
I'm hacking into the mainframe.
I can't even message on your channel.
No, no, no.
It's because we've been signed up.
Fucking...
YouTube does this.
It's like randomly signed up.
Wait, how am I still streaming?
No, you can...
So you can be signed out on OBS that still let you in, if that makes sense?
Oh, okay.
But it's showing that I'm not signed out.
I still have my thingy.
I mean...
What's happening?
Why can't I type in my chat?
Is this like an OBS tape in your chat or on YouTube type in your chat?
YouTube type in my chat.
Right.
You've been signed out.
That's why you just...
Okay, I give up.
Sorry, guys.
I cannot say hi.
No, it wasn't...
No, no, no.
That's where to park in the mainframe.
Hold on.
It wasn't a laughter dead 2 DLC.
I was talking about VTube Studio, by the way, guys.
Not that.
How do I join your game?
The love of God.
Do not show this on stream.
For the love of God.
Oh, wait.
I'm going to just spawn over it.
There you go.
Don't fucking show them.
That's your password again.
And then I'm deleting it once you're in.
You're now a standard moderator.
I'm not even signed in.
I said I'm a standard moderator in your chat when I'm not signed in.
I can't believe it.
Signed out.
Sinking is passed.
Good morning, reflings and harem.
How is it going?
What the hell?
Started any worse.
But we got there.
I'm in.
Right.
I can chat.
Do you hear this error?
Oh, my God.
Wait, did YouTube just shit the bit?
YouTube.
I think YouTube might have just.
Hey, this guy recommended a clip.
It was just that mean?
A anonymous tip to $4.20.
Chat is broken today.
No clip.
I was recommended a clip.
Oh, they're tipping me chat is actually broken.
They broke on stream.
fucking day two dollars guess we're chatting over tips so chatting over
tips oh my god everybody send us sent of a tip okay so chats busted don't worry
reflins and harem if you're typing we are we're now aware the chat is busted
hold on I'm sure it's just fell the reflins being like mommy oh mommy I
think YouTube chat is broken I can't chat or see it updating yeah it's not YouTube
chat is completely broken I guess you're just gonna have to stream snipers so we
can talk then the you need to give a live commentary on the stream in game
okay I'm so bummed right now why would it break today that's so yeah cuz the last
one is people just saying hi I'm gonna hold on is it we just turn this into a
zatsu um let me look on Twitter is are people talking you want to do an
interrogation we get reefing and here I'm in on stream and we interrogate them
two dollars and if they haven't you know we it's called a fake link if you
can't watch every millisecond that of content I produce you're called a fake
link a fake link you're called a harlot derogatory derogatory not to hear
them spank spank I'm just gonna tweet did YouTube just break eternity tipped
three dollars and thirty three cents did you order that I did I did I did
immediately after heart shape right the next thing I'm supposed to get you to
download which apparently you don't have you block you don't have you block what
is you block blocks a lot of piss John omni like we can't speak it's okay
here we've been so you haven't been silent guys five dollars I promise we
haven't yet I'm watching another show and his chat seems fine wow what is it
just us it's literally just us we've been they had to nerf her collab then you
it's too powerful we wait I'm gonna go to somebody I'm gonna go to what about I
see I was bursting in I see I know don't say hold on right both of us it
doesn't work hi dog hi kitty oh my god I can't type in I see stride or she must
be like oh no the snowberries aren't interested in this game and it's like
oh you're literally that scene and interstellar I'm gonna message it right
now YouTube chat and mother can you hear me thank you for the tip don't give me
money yeah don't just use March yeah use March I'll look at Marshmallow $3.33 I
don't have an ad walker suffering I just watch it on my TV because I have
premium I usually want to do on TV it's not just you guys I checked here a
stream from hololive in her chat so broken so it's that way oh my god it's
derogatory I'm gonna go to mozumies okay hello is your chat also broken it
depends how you want to do it we could stream say but just means we don't know
what's going on half the time if everybody mommy I have no voice I must
think I see in me shop channel is back up hey why would you say that I don't know
why you would say that yeah fucking cunt sorry yeah that one that one didn't land
chief I'm gonna be wait what is your cow back hold on hold the fuck wait wait
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wait hold on hold on I'll be
back
that doesn't make any sense that doesn't make any sense okay I take I'm sorry I
called you a cunt you're amazing
oh we're back we're back we're back are we back back
I have to go back to my own chat cuz I've been going other people's chats it's
just me and scrawny just sitting here in the void guys
this picture me pulling you close to my chest and just swinging you around by
your little feets
oh my god that was actually low-key I don't know why that was that was scary
it's like you guys died for a second for me I'm not gonna lie that that scared me
for a good bit um doesn't make any sense how did Amy's account come back cuz I
think what I didn't even send an email and scrawny we're just talking about it
oh oh this is gonna make Amy so happy oh we were sacrificed to the YouTube gods
and I believe it oh oh wow I literally was about to have like a mini panic attack
on stream that's none of you guys know how parasocial we fucking are I guess I
can bring back the fucking I don't know why I should just get back on oh it's
all right it's all right it's all right refling and refling's and had a male
we are fine yeah let me let me bring a spoke both up oh
oh
okay never mind I can't do that
we saw anything Amy sauce she's being she's risen she has she's the second
coming of the messiah the one that was promised
put that cuttlefish down and now I like I like wiggling her around I wish I could
pop her head off and I could stick it on a skateboard like I did like I did with
my head yesterday that would be fun wasn't it and then we can both just have
a little skatepark together I think that'd be pretty neat don't you think so
mommy oh yes I think so very much so that'll be fucking great she be I can't
believe you came up with that that was a really fucking spanking idea yeah she's
helpless oh mom I can't do a single thing looks like I just gotta you know
I'm meeting her hair it's cotton candy flavored
she's lollipop hair you know the first time I saw her stronties model I thought
she was gonna be candy themed her hair is made of fiberglass I'll I don't think
that's so spanking I don't know I couldn't think of anything you two probably
did a system restore a week ago to every account that gore band got restored
because you do look at crap wait wait I want to screenshot that and send it to
scrawny did the people's dude that's just weird fucking timing then what's
spell did I see do
I'm fucking shaken that's so weird look at that look at the message I am shaking
wait what sorry sorry refunds I can't say this okay we're gonna disappear for a
second guys here I'm in reflin we'll be right back a lovely company secrets I love
you both okay bye bye no you're here I'm just I'm just I'm just muting
you
Easiness business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business service business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business business racket professional professional centered professional glide professional professional like you. professional professional professional
You can't you can do this. I can only it's weird, but I can only do it in the back of my throat. I can't roll my tongue
Like I do that, but that's not that's what my you're gonna be a lot. Oh
You got an enlarged you feel like Maricely. Is that a thing?
She's Maricely said it to me. She's like I have an enlarged you feel and I was like, I don't wear my fannies big too
And she was like, you know, I'm not talking about that
Oh
Strani that's
She's by the way, I'm using for anyone says and that was a tease
Sometimes I can come out where joke. Okay, sometimes sometimes she's got she's got jokes. He he okay
I can do it. He he same thing. Hey
Okay for the uninitiated harem on the uninitiated reflakes I
Stony cuttles have a steam account which you can stream snipe and add me on okay
the addition is
Strony snipes now if you don't have my POV up because you're on a she be side
I'm showing it on screen right now
But it's Strony snipes. So what the agenda nation is and I have pieces of paper if you've never done stream sniping
But with me before I have a piece of paper where I write down who's played with us
And who's not and we work on an honor system where you do not play if you have a chance to play
You do not join until we do the reuse system where we read you again. So the train continues. We continue to train you
So you can add me on this account the truth of the matter the fact of the matters
I have never played Left 4 Dead 2 before she be has so we're gonna play some campaign mode
And then I have been heavily heavily heavily recommended to play a game mode
Which is 4v4 zombies versus survivors?
and
So, yes, oh, I didn't even know that was a game mode
Well apparently it's the most popular thing and we can get six reflakes in here a minute at a time
And oh cuz I've never played this game before I'm killing all of you just kidding
Oh, this is gonna be I'm gonna get my ass handed to me. This is this is Dom loss. I can't
This goes against my nature
Management you've been suspended
What?
No, it's like could you've been suspended because you're doing the opposite of your lord? Oh, I was like
No, no, no, it's like
There are so bad. I'm like that gear up. Let me I forgot to tweet out my stream
So so while you get that sorted I will tweet
Who's push to talk? Hello, please talk. I don't what is my talk fun?
Je ne sais pas use
Use voice communication
That's right, I'll catch us in the game. Then we're right. So we can only play with
Play campaign place there a corporate of campaign online. Am I hosting that do you want hype? No, you can hold
I think you might host it cuz you have the bear. Oh wait, I do you have the ethernet cable and yes or no
No, not yet. It won't be here till tomorrow. I'm gonna have fair internet and you
And I'm happy across the globe. You're alone. You also have all the account and stuff. So like oh, yeah dumbass
Play online with friends search for game. No, it's creating a new
Difficulty let's it's the first time I played the game before anyone starts chance shite and
Because I'm putting it on I should just lie and say this is my first
Okay, wait, why is it not just want to make sure you're aware of sprays might be smart to make sure that's disabled
Oh, are people gonna do like sprays and they're all just like no not the cod lobby sprays
Wait, you can like custom make your own spray. I don't know that
Right a fish server type official dedicated. I assume that's the one that doesn't show my IP
Please don't come to my house
I'm the only game create lobby like this. How do I add strongy my account called strongy snipes?
You're suspended
Somebody stop talking about suspensions. I can't handle it
I'm getting nervous. We don't have to use voice chat. No, you're not forced to use watch up
But you can say hi if you want right don't snipe the slots because she be needs to come in
Right, how'd I get you in? Well, why don't you just hide your screen for a second and then I can join
well
I don't think I don't like every phone
Yeah, but
I'm trying to get that chat so I could see both chats
Oh, I never even thought about that. That's fucking genius. Hold on a minute. I see these cook
I
Got
Can let me open up her stream so I can read both channels at the same time
Okay, I got I need a third fucking display, but I don't have enough room. Um, you invited me
There I am
Oh, hey, there's a see there's a harem in here. I knew someone would sneak in
I fuck sake fuck sake they were quick on it, right?
So I need to write down your names now because you are again you so in tip
Oh my god, not Leviathan
Right and then not Leviathan and then I write down the name
So then on the honor system next time when it comes to people that can join right just start game
I guess
What's my push to talk button? I don't know
And they can they just they can hear us delayed
Oh, my bgm is still playing in the background. I turned it on get off get off
While we were talking
Did I tell you you have a second background music technically?
What is the first one the first one I got you came out?
Not correct for you
No, what is it?
Uh, I can send it. Yeah after stream if you want. Yeah, what the hell
I got it concepted it was still based after sonic heroes, but I had whistling in it and it was like no no whistles
No, that's me. So then I just completely got it read on to your current one
Uh, because it did not fit you at all
But that was on me because your design wasn't finished yet and I went ahead and ordered the background music
No, okay
I
Got an achievement if you're reading this achievement Gabe Newell has successfully what?
Gnom alone wait. I have no in-game sound. Oh
What was that achievement name?
I'm a cool dude. Oh my god. Take a break now
Get that look sensitivity wait, this my sound is way too quiet
Right, how do I talk in game test? I don't know
Oh, see it's all right airman reflin. Who's that going? Can you hear me in game?
I can't
Oh my god this game
Wait, there's no aim down side
Oh, I hear you in game
How
No, you can't aim. No. Yeah, it's more source games. You just don't aim down. You just shoot
Me melee is wrong
No, no, this is all wrong. This can't be. Oh, we can hurt each other in game
Yeah, let's not be shitting ourselves. You're a big black man, shiny. This is actually the real me underneath
Um deep down inside. I'm remind me of my father
Where is melee I'm going blind
Hey big man. Yeah, what was that? Hey big man. Wait, is that a reflin talk? No, that's in game. Yeah, that was in game
I give up it's push enemies away. Why would it be called push enemies away?
I mean music sounds like persona
Strani is Papa Sal. I was not expecting the strani face reveal
Hey, thank you
Diego
John omni. I thought you were fucking trolling. I'm so sorry. I genuinely thought you're trolling about that anything
You must forgive me melee weapon. Yes. Apologies. Apologies. Oh god, we're playing gmod
It's not gmod. It's made in source
Pick up the the crowbar is gmod. Well, it goes like like gmod
I'm not being done. No, you're not dumb. It's made in the same engine
I'm being beat up by my own harlot
Okay, uh
Well, let's get to it first impressions of life or dead too. I'm scared already. Is it my gun go?
You either have a pistol or a melee weapon. Oh, you can go like katana mode. Yeah, you can grab a thank you
Stay together to survive. Okay. I understand we will be protected at once. Oh
Sorry. Oh strani you go first. Oh my god, there's so fast
Why I thought this was gonna be like a dead island rip tight. Oh, no, it's not they're not slow
It's like terrifying
Well, they're doing a lot of work. So
I'm just gonna watch strani get attacked by zombies this entire time
Oh my gosh, they have like radio the guys and pistols have unlimited ammo. Okay. Good to know good to know
Oh my gosh
All right, I would not do well as an operative in terms of I would end up like shooting everyone who crosses me
Oh
What is happening? Oh
Wait, wait, wait. What's going on? What does the year hold me? I needed to
I saved the heart
There's like different like little mini boss. Oh, they're like zombies with special abilities
Like a smoker like does like poison gas and you have a jockey that rides you and kind of like eats your head
And that's okay that right
Set it
Fuck I keep missing
I'm sorry. I'm just enjoying myself watching everyone
This is the beauty of stream sniping. I think you've already done a stream snipe game before, haven't you?
I don't think so. Can I jump out the window? Oh
One
I thought you played before I didn't play the campaign
Oh, I played like a game mode with the girls from you may
Oh
pain pills
Refling refling heal up with these pain pills here. I didn't think I thought there was gonna be a wall and I couldn't jump out
I didn't save her from her so funnily enough
God
I assume pain pills heal
How has straughty never played this game? I I am surprised about that
I was sorry. I just show I I just never played it. Just one of the games I never played
Oh pain pills give temporary health. Okay. Yep. Yep. She comes
Oh my god, right, so we'll please
I'm putting this on fire
Oh, it's a spare spare is required. Oh my gosh
Oh my god
You got you got grabbed by by something
Oh my god, I don't like it. I don't like it
That was awful
a smoker
Damn, we really feel strongly about smoker
Smoker, yeah, they got little tongues that grab you to raise a dead player, right? Uh, sure
Sure, I'll just aim bought it from there
Wait, is my body still down there?
Yeah, you're just you're just chilling in a little red outline. You're just there
My purr sheepsters
What are you a boomer has vomited on you, what does that mean? It's like
Poison
Yeah, you're taking health damage. I'm not supposed to be doing melee so I don't hurt you guys
I feel like I'm going to be the reason we die like uh probably me because I died first if anything
Because I
You're going to respawn in a closet. Oh my god, she be you didn't tell me
This is who I truly am
Here I am
Oh, I don't pick you up. Oh
Don't fall off and you baby. Oh my god. No, what's going on?
What is going on? How have you got chainsaw?
Stratis reaction
I'm in a closet. Are you actually I know
That's how you respawn by coming out. I'm coming out. I want the world to know
You
I have a oh, I thought I had a health thing. I guess I don't get mummy get mummy. She be at the closet
I'm just gonna shoot randomly
Like I think the reeflands are way more and the harem are better at the game than I mean
They seem to have melee weapons, which makes me
Oh my god
I'm just gonna sit in this L. Oh get to the elevator. I'm coming to the shaft
Okay, oh god, this is like black ops one zombies. We have to take the elevator
Her name's Rochelle. She is a fucking chainsaw. Are you guys too scared to talk?
They're shy
Oh, I'm put. Whoa. Why is my are we dead?
Are we getting in an elevator? Mike doesn't work. That's what they always say. You're smoking hot budooms
Pride door open to escape
Here they she be a lair at the board
I can swing my sword sword at the evil horde horde the zombie zombie
Shoot my magnum sword sword
I don't
I don't know how many times I'm gonna get notified to not shoot my teammate. I cannot see anything
I'm dying. I have adrenaline
Does this have bullet? Where are we going? I'm following them. I'm following them. Can you see them? Yeah?
Yeah
With the ousi
I could have rolled my tongue. I'm sorry
That's what it sounds like
Stream sniper you need a med kit. Ah shit manual reload face rear enemies. Yeah, no shit
Well, I'm I'm dying from smoking elation is it over here. I have no idea
Oh, I'll save you. Oh, thanks, Queen. Oh
My god, I can't believe your hotel go over run by zombie. I know a wonderland is not looking so good right now
Wonderland more like
Zombie land
Fucking laugh is that a med kit give that to me. Oh, oh how pipe bomb
Morning
The big bleeping red brick of C4 you couldn't see and walked right into it. Are you okay?
All the other vending machines get that corn juice
We're in Japan
But there's the most vending machines in Japan, that's true. Yeah, like her person or maybe just overall
That's right. Strony snipes. Mm-hmm melee fight. Yeah, I did no melee at all. I was at more of a pew pew, you know
coming with a
Okay
That so now we're doing the second map. So I need to kick out the car. Wait, hold on. Hold on. This is wait
Did I spawn no right so we need to kick out the current reflands and add in here
I'm in adding the next round, right? This was a round that was a round. This is gonna say, but I don't know I
Don't have way will that work if we invite them or does it restart the whole thing? I
Don't I don't know if that is considered round two of the first map. Okay, so this this will still keep it
There's five rounds per campaign
You can shift people if you like. Oh, no, but don't
It's been nice. Oh shit. Oh, you know, he just left. I just dipped
Okay, if you leave if you leave is that okay? We're like one round each
I know it's not long, but we're gonna play the eight the 4v4. Yeah, I'll get more of you guys in
Yes, so then can someone out a great run see you
So now they'll be idle and other reflands can join in. Yes, right everyone here lot first things first
I'm the realest
First things first and the reason right we have purely is Alice at the NPC or is Michelle
Alice is the person's name. Yeah, I mean the NPC's name. Oh now it's peanuts the pig
peanut
Peanuts no peanut. Sorry peanuts
Peanuts
Okay, there we go. I've wrote your names down, right? I can get a second pistol
Wait, if you streamstape on the body, you don't have you don't come in with fool. Um, I dual Beretta's the fuck
Curious, okay hydration chair. Yes, I've been slurping
I'm on that cooler grind. I don't know about you, but I'm sipping some lemonade
Oh
All right, I'm ready to rumble I'm ready for your service harlots. Are you scared do you guys talk are you too scared to talk?
Let's find out. Let's find out. It's bitches
Hello, hi guys
Who's more intimidating me or she be what do you think?
That's a great question. I think we both have our traits that are intimidating
You're more intimidating me. Yeah, what why am I more intimidating?
They're just saying that because they're reeflings women in general women
Whoa, what was that a hunter? Yeah, you're a little guy
Yeah, everyone says you jeez. What did she be dirty is good. Yeah, she's I'm terrifying
Yeah, whoa, what's that? Oh, um
What the hell just happened to me I
Saved I came I saw I see
Praise the law. I take what's mine then take some more
They said
They said some people said you add one person that said you but I think it has there your reeflings and they
They may watch me from time to time
As the boy wait to hear him say mostly you or they one of them said me and then one of them said you
Hmm
Who's more dominant she be or is there a I?
I'd actually say she be yeah
I'd say me for that is there a definitely could be Dom when she wants you she can turn that on but she just doesn't yeah
The wish you get a paper. I'm fucking hell
I'm afraid I've got some ancestry that doesn't let me pick up these kind of way. Oh
I
What
My life is a lie
No, no, no, no, so born Scotland Scottish
Parents, but then it goes into Ireland and because of the famine. Oh
I think I'm like 10% Irish
Or like 15 I'm a lot to find my
My ancestry thing. Oh, yeah, I did it. I've been really interesting to look at a major month
Oh
Yeah, I'm a mongrel
Are we mongrel? Oh, we dog. He's so cute. Hello popper. What what a boomer? Okay? Okay boomer
That's it. When am I getting a she be song cover? I'm waiting. I know I needed I was I was strong
I'm like, I can't do the song cover that I wanted to do. It's too hard. So I have to do something else to do
It's actually really hard to
And ironically like before anyone's like oh doing a song cover must be easy
It's actually no, it's very hard to like do it the way you want to do it. And especially and if you don't have any
Oh, I'm sorry
I
Killed the little leaper thing, but then I kept shooting the first time. Oh, there's a lot of
Combination name of harem and refling hairling
Harling harling
Reef um reef um reef um boys. That sounds like a roofing people
I'm a reef you so I'm a reef on this shit. How do you?
Yeah, I reflaw
Why do I just randomly have can I throw this
How I would explode a spitter
Really good
Until I get to you I need to hug to you
To a I don't talk to a yeah, I was like damn all lyrical genius
Because I was writing in short script while listening to she be yesterday
I may or may not popped up on her stream at one point and got a bit incoherent
So what's it? You weren't incoherent. I
was doing
Sheepsters is a
Donut on like goals. I was like implementing her goals because she sent me a screen from what she came up here
I'm and I
Was like torture ASMR and I'm like what what I what what?
I just didn't even know what it meant like what it entailed
And I was having a giggle. I was having a big giggle about it. Um, I
Must protect I must protect protect protect and attack
Pintas you might need a granolin pintas
Probably heal myself
Strony your rule ball voice was so funny. I was dying on the toilet laughing because it was just like
Robotic Scottish noises
No, I killed the boomer
We store a I love when strong he said it's reefing tape and refilled all over
That's how it be
This road is closed. Oh you start
What is that? It's the witch killer hurry
Oh, don't like that. Oh, I
Was just shooting hands. I promise I promise. I didn't know it was a witch
I don't know what the witch does. I honestly don't know what her thing is. I'm gonna say go hug the witch
Hmm. I don't know what she does to you
Someone's crying
Chucky
Okay, go golf club. Oh
Dude behind us, where is he?
Can't shoot him if you shoot her she rushes to you and
I am going to
Thank you
I'm I'm in I didn't mean to
Couch, don't shoot
Actually saves you, but please don't spray me with bills. Okay. That is a reasonable request
She gave me adrenaline is
Looks like an EpiPen because that's what an EpiPen technically is
A little cheeky injection. I'll go first because I'm close to death use me as fodder
No, no, we want you alive
Oh
I didn't think he'd jump on me so fast
Careful what you wish for
You're in my life. I'll buy our peanuts
He's chugging them pills they're giving you adrenaline to keep you alive
Do not hug the witch she'll down you faster than you say and oh, shite
Oh
So maybe I'm out of bullets
You got pistol
No
I'll chop them up through this fence
Whoa, whoa
I have AKs
Oh
That's 12. Oh my god, they went out on the guns
We were I'm not the reserve the right to refuse service to anyone. Yeah
Okay, I got dfib
Talk to the gun shop owner
Good morning. Welcome. Hey, there's a heel here. Healed. Thank you
Yeah, poorly is keeping me alive. Let me grab that other heel
That's right for once you guys are the heel slots. Yeah, that's right
This is what it feels like to be pampered this never happens
Your target laser upgrade makes your whip and more accurate
Oh
To get a laser sight. Yeah, you want a laser sight it's back here
It's in here
And see that there's a laser sight
It is just this little thing in the boba here
And then boom. Oh
What's up? Finally girl
Okay, my ankles aren't good enough to jump off the belt. Yeah, I don't I don't recommend it
Talking for personal experience
Oh my god, I remember you
What I don't you walk the whole way around
Oh
I just like I'm came down there
I thought you could go with the hedge be ready to fight the lord. I'm ready to fight the whores
Bring on the whores
The rogatory though
Behind your forward. We are retrieve the cola inside. Honestly me though
No, wait
Okay, okay. Are you in fire? Yeah, don't worry about it. It's fine. I have health
I scored the cola delivery. What?
How did I kill the jockey? Oh, I was with my malt off
Oh
Cat food my dispenser my beloved
I love editing stuff for she because I'll just fucking go off randomly
I think I went off when I was recording something
Take the trailer
Yeah, she be recorded her doing this one like trailer
and
And it was like sorry, uh, boomie was making a noises in the background. Let me try that one again
And then it's like cat feeder thing goes off. All right. Sorry. Let me try that one again
I'm like never I usually just like add all that out. I'm like, I'll leave it in she'll get it
She'll get a lot. I'll leave. I like doing it. I'm actually kind of sad that I'm not gonna be editing as much anymore
But I really like whoa
Oh
Oh, I'm shouldn't I know I'm am I stuck all those people all around me
All around me are familiar faces
More now
Thank you
Would you be done for college a six?
Yeah, I would that's why I was trying I had an fps week because I was uh
Get my fps reps up
You know, we can grab here and we film from behind when we do that game, right? Oh, yeah, we can use them as body shields
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, what do you what did you mean?
When you grab them from behind you have direct voice chat open like the microphone goes open to each other. That's the that's the body
And then uh, you can whoa
You can see like really inappropriate stuff like right into their ear holes. Oh
Dream snappers may be shy, but we'll get one that talks. I know it one of you will talk
Don't you guys want to talk to us?
Why don't you talk to me?
They're scared
The one vocal I mean, am I really that intimidating?
Who is that where did that come from?
Who's there? Who's there? There's someone there's someone
Somewhere around the weapons are like really strong. I like it like it feels like when I'm shooting. I'm actually doing stuff
Getting sad the safe room
To poorly just say something. I don't know
I never heard anything. I saw the like chat bubble thing. This picture is a stressed out dog
Who did the most damage to you? Oh, look at you strongy with your 409 just behind porno
It's such a good weapon. What weapon are you using?
Uh, I don't know what it's called. I'm 16 the pew pew
Killed the most special infected rub me just aimbotin. I'm like, hmm something wiggling shoot shoot
Oh scar. Yeah, that's a scar guys. Leave me alone
I thought you were supposed to be the american
If they could be americans, I don't know
I know is this stuffy. I woke up from a nap
My chat was there working. I have a headache. Give me some slack guys
Well, thank you for the extended three month membership. Yeah
I guess that big whoa
Uh, right reeflands, you're welcome to stream snipe in from my friend's list
You should be able to just see me and join game because there's no one in an xy
Sad cat. Thank you for the extended membership. I know I'm supposed to be in the middle of a collab to do it
I'm unprofessional. Okay. We're uh, I don't give a shit. Um, yeah
Did you like did you pin your friend code? No, I can't even talk
It talk it. Okay. Nice english for one
and I can't even
I don't know. I'll try again. I'll try again. Okay. You should be able to do it now
Okay, street uh steam
Set team account is scrawny
Senai
This oh, I can't let me talk. Okay. I think the fix the token these boots are nice
And that's just I wish they would fix the freaking uh, raid message issue
That
Oh, literally
Like it's really nice redirecting into someone like
Outside of the agency like if no one else is on or whatever. Yeah, but when they're like, who raided
Who is that?
I'm like, hi, it's me. Sometimes I don't even say anything. I'm just like, no
I'm like, I'm too tired of the industry. I'm like, fuck it. It's a reflet thing
I always say like thank you for babysitting the reflands or something like that chair
Thank you for the three membership. Oh my god, our freebies. It's wilfred mother fucking wash stash
What a name
Markiplier fan over here
Wilfrid's do you talk who's other hello wilfred?
Annexie
Do you talk fuck's sake?
Name has mics the reflands were telling me that they don't even talk in game that they don't have
Again
I heard that
How do I make you talk loader? Yeah, how do I turn up game chat voice transmit volume
Test
Where's the voice transmit volume speak
Speak
Replace your low ammo weapon. No, I'm just gonna get more ammo. Right. I'm a healer. Oh, I heard that but it's so quiet
Yeah, it's still so quiet
Oh, we're see it's probably receive volume
Nice it's quiet
Speak fuck good boy. I know that reference. That's a husky video because it's so cute
All right speak mother fuckers
I am speaking
Okay, I turned up the receive so that's what you gotta turn up
It's a little bit better. All right now meow for me
I'm so quiet. We're not gonna be able to hear them once we leave the safe room, but I'll take it
I'll take it. I'm trying to get these pussies to meow for me and they're not
One of them me out
Oh, wait, I'm allowed to hold
Uh, okay. Okay. Okay. I'm learning. I'm learning right. I'm ready. I'm ready. I'm ready
Uh
This is not like Italian music
Ah, oh sorry
Reloading uh, why doesn't say I'm protecting you when I'm clearly like somebody attacks me and you
But you just happen to shoot me at the same time
Wait, the zombies are fighting each other. I want to read. Look at these. They have really nice, uh, mannequins
Oh, just getting distracted
We appear to be in what is known as a shopping mall a shopping mall
A shopping mall. Look at that. They've got escalators. That's when you know
They mean business when it's got big escalators. That's when it's a big business when you get escalators
Is uh
How is it called? Um
I heard there's like loads of abandoned
Moles in america now because like no one has money. Nobody. Yeah, nobody goes. Everybody's online. They just shop online too
Ah
Where are you? Oh, you're right next to me
I'm like trying so hard right now. I'm enjoying this. This is a good game. Yeah, it's pretty fun
Uh, I'll be very interested to see how this 4v4 thing goes
As I said, we're not going to do too much cam
Pain, I don't know if the campaign's like can I come under?
Yes, you can come under
Three two one go
I'm kidding. I'm teasing. I'm teasing. I'm teasing for a pleasing. Okay
I cannot scratch my eye. My eye is wondering what's happening to me
I'm gonna brought her to tears
I've been
Proof that I'm abusing
I've been abused
Hell
Oh, I got a piece of cat here in my eye
I'm blind
If I was playing this alone, I have to admit I'd be absolutely terrified right now
But I'm actually doing really good. Oh, I get terrified playing on my own like
Uh
In elden ring like I've finished it now the reef lens like streamsnake me and hold my hand the entire way
Because I get too terrified to play on my own like I get so scared. I can't spawn them in after a boss fight. That's so funny
I just what did you how far did you get? Did you get to the dlc? Yeah, we did everything together
Yeah
Stand there
I mean I commentate on their face. They do really well
That's so funny me who took like two hours to fight a boss the other day
Oh, no, no, I just
We just um because I'm so stubborn
And they're like no, no, but I'm like, no
You play it how they want to play it. There's someone crying. Can we rescue humans in this game? No, that's the witch
That's the witch
My human that is not a human that
I got her
I thought we could save humans. I was like, oh, maybe there's more
And that's how they trick you
They got me
Is there any like
No, you play it the right way like uh, I saw the monkey game and I thought oh, you'd like that
Cause it's like same kind of style and like you're like a proper gamer though. I am not a proper gamer
You're a proper gamer for certain games. You just don't like souls likes
I just they're like, oh, are you gonna play like the
Uh, what is dark souls 3 or something like that the most like well recommended one
And I'm like, well, if you can't carry my hand through I'm a bit useless
Andy'd probably be more scared because I feel like dark souls 3 is a little bit more scary
No, like I get frustrated fast as well. Like if it doesn't go my way. I'm raging. I'm like, no, you rage quit
No, literally like I have to purposely plan around games that I know I can complete or not going to frustrate me because I played this old childhood game called
Blinks and I was fucking screaming at it. I was not having it
Rage it
I also rage at elden ring. Sometimes I have to be like I have to take a step away because otherwise
I was smashing my controller the other day
She uh, clip it and ship it boys
By the way, uh, I went and investigated. I was like, actually, yeah, I have sent these fucking shorts away like ages ago. What's going on? Yeah
Oh, sorry, sorry
You can melee them to
death
What is going on
There's too much. I need space to shoot. I need space to shoot. Can I say
I'm legally blind
I'll take that
Every schema behavior
There you go
I have no idea. I'm following them. I swiped it multiple times. So that's a controller. Yeah
Because I had a one controller that was already broken. I kept it around specifically so I could break it further when I get
Oh
honestly
There's a dwindle in if you would like it. I have some a dwindle in
Whoa, there's chippies. You got some laze. You got some cheetos
You gotta look like a
Some candy
I'm out. Oh dry. I'm back to a pistol
Oh
That one the like five nights at freddy's two folks who jumpscare was that
What was that? Uh, brother. Oh, brother. Oh, brother
I think I'm gonna need a melee weapon. I set fire
Sorry, I'm
I'm not me and I'm not mean to fire
I'm being ridden and not on my strip
Where's the fire alarm
Wait, you turn it off. You know, you have to turn it off. Yeah
And they just keep coming if we don't get up in time, but I'm going I'm running
Where's the right way? I promise you scots are good at short distances. Oh Jesus christ
I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. I'm stuck. I'm stuck
Okay, I'm going. I'm going. I'm going. I'm dodging. I'm dodging. I'm sneaking. I'm so good
Let's go on sash. Come on
Come on. That's it. I'm nuking myself. Fuck it. It's been great. It's been great. It's been fantastic
I just ran over to you setting fire to you and an XE. Very nice
Now he's on fire the zombies like act like they're on fire. I wonder if my
Oh
Can I raise you? Yeah, I don't know. I'm gonna deactivate the ship, bro. I need ammunition. Do it
I'm fucking the horn. Someone take off the horn
This is why I'm just a lion. Literally
Give me this gun
Let me out of here. Wait the fucking alarm. Did we get it? Yeah, they already did it
Oh, I was letting you do it, but I think one of them did it
Oh here all of us are like host after that
I'm feeling you please
Oh, thank you. What me? Oh, you should. Oh, no, you didn't use it on yourself. Yeah, but it's fine
Can I stab you with this? Stab me with what? Oh the adrenaline? Probably
Give no, no, just do it to yourself and give it to myself
I'm gonna let you figure this out
Sorry about that old chap. Imagine watching yourself like slowly die. Oh, no, one of you guys take that
Take it
Take one of you. Take the take the first day. I'll be your little heel slack. You're getting pocketed. Okay. Don't resist
We should heal the people actually play better
Hold on Ray. Okay. Okay. You got you got boy in there. We got point there. I'll be your little heel slack
There we go
I got thanks
You're welcome
I hope you do come well
Oh my god
I got a pipe bomb. Oh, there's a Hulk. I believe his name is Hulk
Okay, that did it work. I'm on fire
Okay, we're good. We're good. We're good fell over standing
I'm still standing
Then
Oh
It's Elton John, but it was in the
Kids movie with the animals
And the monkeys. Yeah, I am
Eggie. Yeah, Taryn. Taryn eggerton. That's right from
Yeah, Kingsman. Yeah, you know it. I love this one. Yeah
I watched it with my mom. She likes movies. She just like watches kids movies because everything scares her
Honestly, I felt that in my bones
She she's just like you want to come over and watch the new um
Like if movie I mean like
Or is it like it I can't remember it or if
Not the one with the evil clown
With the one with Ryan Reynolds and imaginary friends and I'm like mom
Why are you watching kids movies and she's like because everything else is bad
violent
I'm like, okay. Oh, there's pictures of markiplier and then that one's an anime girl
Imagine we were playing a micro plier. Oh my god
The real okay, please with the real slum shady. Please stand up. When's the movie coming out mark?
When's the movie? Where's where's iron long?
Uh, right. Thank you so much for your service reeflings and harem. Thank you. I'm so sorry if I can prepare
The harem is reeflin. If you identify as a harem, I'm sorry. I'm very used to stream safe in a course
You're welcome. Oh, they're already gone. It's a refer to load
Or whoa, what the fuck does that mean share stream? No get the what?
Don't ask to watch my stream and steal
Yeah, it's like this this user is asking to watch your thingy and I'm like, no
You'll never guess what my youtube channel or nor
Oh, I can get a paddle. Oh this paddle. I have a cricket bat
real male
Actually sure though
This is your chance to be the male vtuber that I hate so have fun
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. It's a callback
Time healer wait someone needs to stream snake the roost have got a bot
Well, no, we have jess. Jess is not a bot. Oh jess. This is the name. Oh, I'm sorry. I thought the jess was the character's names
I'm so I'm so sorry. I'm sorry. Okay. I'm small bring
No new ammo I had to drop my
Was it lift your head up your headset falling off king
Right, there's no right. I think the defibrillator is just a woman
What does it say? Where is sedah? This is not no
Oh disappointing. I was hoping we get like a girl harem or roofling
I want to discord kitten
Don't believe the signs washing your hands won't help my bad
The gamers for crayons
What oh crowding wait london why is it london randolines game gamers for crowding?
I know probably probably easter eggs that like
People have played the game. They just put stuff in or maybe the dev team right. We're ready to tag them and tag them and drag them
Indeed
Hmm
First thing that harem does is go into the ladies bathroom. What's going on here? What's going on here?
That was me. I'm the harem. I'm the harlot 350 paying. Who was 350 paying?
Oh damn
Oh, it's because she's australian. That's why
Wait, I'm not. Oh, no. I'm hosting it. Yeah. I would have 216 pain right now
The ethernet came off
Excuse me. It appears. I am the problem. I truly am. We need to fill this car
Famed a gas can well, there's one up there
I think
Whoa
We missed them. Wait, that's
Oh my god, this is a big map
Can I just jump out the window?
I can't are you serious? I have to wait for this fucking stupid thing. Please make it please don't jump
We've already done it once but that was that wouldn't have been
That wouldn't have been a fall
I got it. I got a gas can
What do you do with it? I don't know
Oh, I just threw it at it
Oh, there's something there's like a pouring fuel me 13
We got to collect the 13 notes
Okay
Uh
Wait, so it's a real car. Did they display real cars in malls? Yeah
Oh, that's really cool. Can I jump down?
Oh, what are you serious?
Uh, how'd I get up to you? I'm coming. I'm coming. Jess got me
Okay, okay, very stupid. I try to jump over the edge and I
It's like a teammate must have helped you up
No, I see. Oh, there's med kits in the next to the car to the uh
I don't know what happened to the gas can I dropped. Oh, I think already got it
Yeah, uh, he dropped it on something where I cannot reach
Jess, what have you done? Okay, I got it. It's fine
Right. Yeah, hold on. I'm figuring out. I want the defibrillators in case someone goes down
I'll I'll give you the kiss. Was it the kiss of life? They call it if you get saved by
Someone giving me a kiss of an angel
I'll be your I can be your angel and she'll be your devil. Oh wait, I'll be your angle and she'll be your devil
Yeah, I'll be your angle
Yeah, keep throwing them down. I'll keep pouring them in
Can I throw it up?
Oh, oh my god
And that song is stuck in my head from saying
Oh, I got pills
They're multiplied
It's electrified
Yes, we're doing karaoke together. Yeah 100%
Oh
Can somebody get my back, please help
Santa line of fire, how can I not?
Better row your tongue from the
I'm just being having gas cans thrown at me
Oh, no, you're so low health. Hold on. The only person that's allowed to ride chibi is a harem. Not a jockey. Oh my god
I'm so close to death. Hold on
There's loads of medkits. Hold on. I can see the end of the bar from the the bar next to the car
There's a pack to help your
existence
Well, the sound design is really good because I can hear exactly where they're coming from. I know, right?
Where's the other two? Oh, it's right here. Oh, what's up fricker rootie?
Hell, oh my god, shrani's like carry me
um
I don't even know how i'm doing this so well to be honest
Maybe because I put it on easy mode. Who said that?
Who said I did not this is legendary modes. What are you talking about?
This is legendary. Let's get in the car. I'm stuck. I'm stuck. I'm literally stuck
Cussing we got cussing
You mean legendary exactly
Oh, we got like a kill cussing survive the dead center campaign. We escaped
Okay, oh my god, we get credit
I was
I love games that credit you. Oh my god. Damn right. I'm coach. Mmm. Pippin number of times
The first aid kits use
This is zero everything gang. Yeah, I didn't realize
It wouldn't like counting or something
Do like blues brothers and drive around the mall honestly
Common infected kill
Kill the most affected shrani with four 10
We're gonna be at the top of the lobby all the time. We'll do one more
And then we'll do that four v four game mode whatever it is. I have no idea what it involves, but we're gonna do it
We're gonna do it. Let's do it
707 zombies were harmed in the making of this good number. Stop. I love this game
Well, this is no wonder it's so well received. This is like such a good game
Right, so edit game sentence is that changed the map chapter?
Wait, we could do the campaign in one day
Hmm
Tempting
But how much time do you have my darling she be girl? I got nothing going on. I'm gonna go get some more water
Actually, hold on. I need to feed my cat
Yes
Because the thing went off 20 minutes ago
Wait, it's a different map. Oh, oh wait, hold on
Leave the lobby
Play campaign
Play with pals
Great of lobby but not that. Oh, no, we cannot complete the campaign
There's too much
I don't have much. We ain't doing campaign. We'll do this
I can't hear where before
Why is the floor sticky surprise I was over air
I
Please play no mercy. Oh, I was gonna do it in order
I think what I'll do is I'll play one more campaign
For this stream snip and then we'll do the 4v4 game mode just for the rest for the shits and giggles
And then I'll play the campaign
With the refunds at a later date
We'll do the campaign together because I thoroughly enjoy this game. I'm enjoying it
I did not realize how good it was like this is 10 out of 10
Hello, are you hungry?
Hello, thank you for waiting
Munch, munch, munch, munch
Sorry, I'm just uh
Doing some management stuff behind the scenes whilst I have a taking the advantage
Oh, fuck
That was me. That was my pc. Sorry refunds and theorem. Uh
I just need to make sure that I'll just climb I alone
I'm uh, I'm having to start a new map. Don't worry. Um
Uh, so what we'll do is we'll play one more
and
Don't snipe the fucking lobby. She's not in
I'm I'm getting in hold on. I'm just oh, there we go. No, don't snipe the fucking lobby. Yeah, it's said there's not enough slots
Oh, yeah, but yeah, I mean the navy dinner the navy dinner. Don't do that. Don't do that
Don't do that
Right play with friends. It takes me long enough to create the lobby. Okay. Please be nice to me. This is not easy for me to do
Right, no one come in
Right, and then you're bare
Hi, marie
You must wait until she's in I'm in it's not even I'm gonna get 10. Okay, and then you can do your free throw. Okay. Hold on. I have to pee
Okay, no, that's fine. That's fine. I'm gonna mute but
Hold on. I need a mute on discord and on my chat
Chief of oh, wait. No, I press this button
Chief of police as in
Does that say master kush? I swear to god if that says master kush
It so does doesn't it?
What is her name?
Oh, I can't see you
I'm so oh you're playing satisfactory. Yes, that's factor 1.0 came out master keith. It's old
He he he you peeler allegation and I can't believe I have to unironically message a talent and say hey
Have you peed on an audio yet for your donut's on reward?
Hey, hey, can you piss?
Hey, can you can you tinkle?
You
Right anyway, sorry, um as you can imagine I'm rather
Hello
Can you hear me? I can't hear anything
Mummy next time you can just change the campaign in the lobby. Oh
I'm gonna give it a shot offline to see if I'll be able to play it or not. I'm not sure though
Sorry for taking she be spot early about no, don't actually be sorry. I'm not actually mad
It's just because I know she be needs to come in but if people are trying to stream snipe the slot before I can even get
She be in I'm like
Give me a moment. Um as for my lovely reeflings. Um
Sorry here. Um, I know you're lurking in the shadows. I apologize. Um
I will most likely play left for dead campaign with the reeflings
So you guys can stream snipe me for the campaign and we'll have some shenanigans afterwards
I'm not going to ask she be of too much time. However, um
Because uh, she's working on her finalizing the donut on and we're we're getting some, you know assets and all that trash, you know
it is
So I'm not going to ask too much time
Do I count down from win to enter? Yeah, three
seven
Two you're getting closer
One
You're almost the lead to enter
Zero you can come and the lobby
um
Um
Mummy don't mind me if I'm rubbage. I'm a bit rusty. Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no
Um, we're literally playing easy mode because I've never played this game before but can I just say
For when did this game come out? I'm pleasantly surprised
um
how like how good it feels like the guns feel nice the weaponry feels nice and it doesn't feel
overwhelming the audio cues are fantastically placed like fantastically played this is lovely
game 2009 okay this i'ma say it this game i might rank it a 10 out of 10 already like it's so fair
and it's so like considerate to the player if you want and there's medical supplies where you
need them just i think this is a fucking well rounded polished game and i don't know how long
development was i wouldn't mind but yeah this is really good and really really good i know it was
highly rated but i just never got a chance to play it the game director is very nice um
are you nervous wait you're nervous why are you nervous to play with me i'm not going to say
anything mean i'm not a mean able beanie don't be nervous to play with me it's because it's about
development was one year they put this together in a year the mechanics are easy to pick up the gun
play is great and it switches up um tanks oh it switches up thanks to the director yeah leford ed
was released it's actually more generous the shit seriously more mid spawn when your teams have lower
health literally i think i fell down i don't know yeah so to speak amongst yourselves we're just
discussing the game um and i'm seeing that's a really good game i'm i'm very pleasantly surprised
i i just never got the opportunity to play it and i'm so glad that i get to play i mean fuck like
this is going to be unironically not to get sappy or anything this is going to be cemented in my
heart because not only did i get to play the game for the first time i got to do it with sheebie and
i also got to do it with harem and reefland are you are you trying to make me cry right now
because i will i will cry everywhere i seriously i get to the um like i stream sniff a lot with
the reeflands but so what happened was on the schedule i planned this game but i was it was
just going to be me and you reeflands and then sheebie messaged me out of nowhere she was um i
didn't expect it and she was like can i play with you and i'm like uh yes you want to stream
together like it the thought didn't even cross my mind that it was even possible that
i could collab and also play at the same time at like both and like i'm just uh i'm very i'm a
very happy being right now that i get to experience this for the first time with you it's very nice
my heart is very full so thank you for yeah thank you for asking seriously because i i
didn't cross my mind that it was possible so yeah i was like oh harem has been asking like
if what i'm gonna do left for dead two again and i'm like i don't know i really don't have
anyone to play with and then i saw it on her schedule and i'm like oh maybe shawnee will
let me play with her in the reeflands and then she said yes are you serious yes
uh right had the putters been fed check on boomie being fed uh boomie is currently eating i'm
still feeding fia okay little sorry fia's taking her time she's getting she gets distracted
take all the time she wants sometimes she's a madame of a high caliber
hey will you eat from my hand ma'am sometimes she needs to switch between the bowl in my hand
i don't know why it has a good mods community as well can i put bigger boobs on my model
and you're a guy imagine oh oh wonderful
i like the nice one all the men have you unironically can there's a mod for that
wait can i make all the zombies like zombie girls and it's like oh no they won they won
i don't know i want my puppies they want the ink you will never have the reefling ink it's
inside me all along yeah are you done wait there's a lot different mods so i wouldn't
be surprised if you can i had anime girls as zombies if you ask someone they can make a
model of you and the girls what imagine us i'm sorry that's too much to ask for i think i'll
do minecraft skins how about that i'll be a cheeky sword and ask for minecraft skins if anyone knows
me so i don't have to pay someone to do it because i don't know how it works they're pretty
they're pretty cheap though i got like a really good minecraft skin for like 15 bucks i think you
can uh five a cut zombie you can have rule 34 mod support and life for dead too i don't think
we'll be streaming that one and i feel like a picky eater today because she's constipated she
has like a fat belly because she hasn't pooped in like two days i feel so bad do you have what's
called a licky lick in america it's just like a tube of liquid food oh yeah it's like a stupid tube
those will get some water in her yeah oh no she'll drink water it's like the food it's like she knows
it's because of her medication she has like a little pot belly right now i feel so bad
i usually give her like me relax and then that are like elixative and i honestly thought you were
about to say i give her an anima and i was like oh i could i won't give up an anima
no i was gonna i was like resistance in that i was um i have a i used to have a boy cat and he was
the funniest cat ever proofing back in scotland and i took him to the vet and he was really attached
to me so he purred a lot um his name is bean little bean um and he was attached to me at the hip
so he used to purr and he was at the vet but he was purring every time i interacted with him
and then he got a thermometer shoved up you know where and then he burst out purring even louder
and i was like what's going on here like the vet started laughing as well because all of us were
like staring at the cat like excuse you like who's obviously the vets are like oh the cat hates this
part so just hold them down or whatever and he starts purring louder i'm like uh bean have you
got something you'd like to tell us bean like something stuck up is bean i like this one i'm
although some cats like to purr like for anxious is like self-soothing so hopefully
that cat was reefland coded right you're done don't don't type about my cally and harem coded to be
honest oh oh i know i'm not allowed to do boomi it's just water comes down boomi's like try to steal
food i need to give the kitty her meds my little pooders is it liquid medication yes
ah that'd be easier for her to take yeah it's uh fish flavored so she does she takes it like a
churu like one of those little tubes so i'm okay thank you stash power for the tip this game popularized
for player horde shooting and they all draw some inspiration from this game the mod that came with
this and other val games helped innovate the modding community as well oh i believe it no i
didn't i don't believe that very much too narrow a cod zombies on black ops who streamed the fun
did they fix the servers on the old them ti crimson thank you for the extended membership
just got home how are they doing you guys protecting our favorite girls they're scared of us
we've had like two people talk in the mic and no one else we're playing one more round of the
campaign and then we're going to be playing a game mode which is four v four um so we'll take it from
there honestly i think for all the tips at the end all those messages i'll read your tips right now
show me them i'll read them out for you okay it's so i think thank you leo i still say she
beats background music sounds like the music from persona five thank you no one special just
want to make sure your sprays okay i got the one before thank you again no one special then thank
you anonymous youtube came after the whole core this is when the chat went down thank you doki
we've been silenced thank you thirdly chat is broken in both streams hey this is sad it's like a
reliving trauma trauma help us madam we're stuck in the void my cat boomi apparently donated two
dollars guess this is the only way to chat damn you neil cat is broken today i guess we're chatting
over tips now thank you you're grand you're again son tip you're you're playing with us so thank you
thank you for playing with us as well you know i can never pronounce your name all right fia has
gotten her meds she has been fed and watered she just we're showing each other the tips real
i want to read the tab just the tab
oh my what the fuck was that i got better i was actually hating at this whole time yeah i was
like you're you're transforming into something i took i took some meds so hopefully my headache
goes away i took i took an allergy pill an allergy pill and a suit of fed so because i have like some
congestion i think that's what's giving me a headache because i want to keep playing
yes oh yeah fuck you have a migraine no it'll hopefully i'll play for as long as i can and
then you guys can just stream snipe without me okay i'll probably be like i'm not even gonna
tell me too much because i'm screaming down the mic being like i say oh that's fine it's really like
motion motion stuff might get me um okay some lemonade i'm drinking water
why would you need lemonade for that is that cure or am i being dumb i need some piss um i don't
know i can't sit with a zero i could just be having like i think i like um i like moved my
neck a certain way like that could also be the reason like i got arthritis in my neck so
oh no are you joking you're so young i know i have arthritis on both sides of my neck and
shoulders i'm destined to get uh on my hands and my wrists but i've not had it i was not started yet
but my grand like had fucked up hands and wrists uh because of it so i'm destined unfortunately
because it was on my on my dad's right carpal tunnel yeah my mom got it around my age too
she didn't expect me to get i immediately i got arthritis after getting covid
i had the weirdest thing that's when i got diagnosed with fibro that's when i got arthritis
all after i had no symptoms before that and then it set off like a genetic bomb in my body
oh my god that's crazy i'm like i'm too young at the ripe age of 56 you know
uh right are the putters being fed yes did you hear boomi just then no i didn't actually he just went
uh because he just peed and ran away from the litter box uh why did the cats do that oh my
god gimley takes a big massive shite and then starts running through the house i'm like
they're like i feel so much lighter literally so like it feels like a feather start floating
around the house like get done get done get done pink get done no boomi you can't hop up here you're
just in the freaking litter box you gross cat go away are we ready i'm ready ready five nights at
is this what you want to go at just don't wait it looks like faces were edited on top of the bodies
we should edit my loading stream nobody survives the inking forever you'll ink one way or another
one way or another we're gonna ink you we're gonna get you one way
this is a fun net fun fun map yeah i don't know which map we played before when i played
that was that you make us girls oh pardon me tea i was interjecting wrong you're fine
ad streamer how dare you speak speak unless unspoken to or something
oh god it's raining
what do you mean 10
oh it died hello bark bark for us now bark
oh
oh you're a black lady now oh my god i'm shabby are you awake i'm a white man as i was meant to be
oh you're waiting ah if you're awake and we could swap saves
like team like and trouble and terror is 10 oh my gosh oh me we gotta play ttt
we honest well maybe let me do the gary's mod test stream uh well test sorry it's off it's not an
off collab it's a off off stream collab because i'm sorry we're testing stuff out maybe we can
play ttt and prop on it if she be leaks it i'm allowed to leak it i've never played gmod before
that's another game oh you're gonna have so much fun if you like this you're gonna have fun
hi miwa miwa saying not the transracial stream
oh my god what was that freaking marshmallow you go it was a copypasta i think
i thought it was real i thought it was real too but then i realized wait no it's a copypasta
and i was what what did i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming nice don't touch cars you saved uh chief
of police chief of police oh i get it is it like chief of police i'm crouching around the car i'm
well don't touch the car don't touch it just look look with your eyes touch with your eyes touch with
your eyes i can't none of us can get in there's stuff on the other side oh we gotta go through
this window and you merely in you can go through the window oh my god oh jeez louise i love this gun
i think it's an uzi get adrenaline no can we you just fucking yoink that for me brother
wait how did you guys get in hold on a minute oh yeah that's right you got it you got it you got it
yeah hold on wait is there whoo actually let me take the shotgun this time i didn't take it last
minute watch out some calls set off the long which way do we go now that's why oh i think there's
refunds i don't like that i don't i don't like that one bit i don't like being in the bathroom alone
okay we can go upstairs up the stairs he's coming up the stairs oh that's where that club is from
jeez that was really funny um there's like this clip where it's like morgan freeming and i'm creeping
around oh yeah yeah it's because there's no no no that was uh i think they're playing stalker
oh is that not no that's not gmod uh i think played myself played myself
hey i got an achievement i have no idea what they're shooting
pow right in the kisser yeah right in the key i'm more focused on talking than uh
this is actually playing the game so i'm just walking around and firing wildly
the best kind of no but those are the best games where you can just yep your head off i was playing
solo and chained and just absolutely blabbing and blabbing and blabbing and blabbing and blabbing
in the distance there's a hulk the two someone said they have 2000 hp and apparently they have
a music track but that's i'm scared i'm stuck on the car i can't see because of the names i can't
see oh okay there i'm empty enough he's gone nice nice job oh tech ninja where are you brother
come here come here come here nope healing myself
uh it's ready to scrub moose button to put it on someone else to be a we heal sign
watch out some cars set off alarms why are you crouching is the car alarms gonna go off the
if you shoot them oh that was the dude i just healed i have dare you i was sneaking i was that
was like ah oh he's got no he over here i don't want to get i'm closing the door they can't come in
if we close the door i don't want to get pinned i hear screeching oh oh my god they're breaking
my door do you know how much i paid for that i just got this down mortgage i got incendiary ammo
you good dragons i can share it with you guys oh frick i just fell wait i'm gonna drop it where are
you uh let me drop it country fine deploying incendiary ammo
i've got her six don't you worry you like that boom so it's in the next stranny it's over here
uh oh that's right there
i'm so low ammo though i can use this for like five
okay i'm good i'm good i'm good kill it don't keep it in two seconds i've been jumping on a survivor
i got an achievement my strong all right denied
reflin scrub it up dumb it's time to get in the tub do you guys want to come in the tub with us
oh my god we're scrubbing in the tub scrub it up dumb we're hanging in the tub i what is happening
down there what did i just walk into
i'm dying and you guys are taking a bath
oh right okay okay okay all right no more no more erp in in the middle of live for dead
heal steve was great oh thank you for the heals i'm doing it that's all yours
i feel so good brand spanking new
right oh fresh from debut where do we go now i guess it would be i'm looking at are we all
where are we going lead the way three flings and theorem
choice say no more back in the tub like here wait how did you get up there she
oh there's stairs yeah yeah you know the staircase yeah the power of flight
be honest oh there's guns where back here they're over here they're over here
mmm yummy yummy i have got my nose it's just all right so we're streamed to 0.0
you'll never guess it's gonna have a stream snow
oh unless there was a roll through this power through this park let's go
oh oh yeah i'm spraying and praying i assure you he's on fire oh it's any look it's her green
dress oh in me oh the body's really just appear quick it's blue for me but green shoes she didn't
look too good oh i wonder it must be instant oh it's a wedding don't touch don't touch
how do you turn them off oh if
i think she's region anyway can't i just shoot her well i can i just shoot her
do you want to yeah what the fuck i'll back you up if you all right i'm back fucking
get up get up get up get up get up get up what is going on her shit freaking bomba
did i just do i don't want to i don't want to sneak pass i'm not going in sneaky beaky i'm i'm
killing bitches no sneaky beaky we do cheeky bricky only here exactly all guns all guns no trigger
discipline all guns are blazing oh oh my god listen to the sound design oh my god it's like
a someone here i know it does go ear to ear look at that
it's like so easy my listen to the pet or pattern talk to the beast 10
oh it should like i can't i'm fighting off zombies right now
oh sorry oh is that the safe house over there
so are we just special or are we just built different in terms of the lore of how i we
survive but everyone else is a zombie we've not met like one other human yet well there's
there's a dude on the intercom that owned the gun shop
you it
sorry i'm trying to keep up okay get that fucking closed get a fucking ghost it's been great gentlemen
yeah we did it we did it strawberry carrying
well so people are you like you carried morgan's the tank he did more damage
but you're literally 20 points behind me man 28 i look my gun just go pew pew and
sometimes the bullets connect sometimes they don't it's a toss up honestly it's a toss up
if it works or not thank you very much for your service
strutty kills 12 special infected what the hell i don't even i'm just shooting when
there looks like there's something bad it's not working thank you thank you farewell
you bye bye okay it was fun you're so right preach preach to the choir because it's working
hey we're gonna get back issues you got scoliosis or her dumpy is just huge
iridocyclitis i haven't heard that in a long time iridocyclitis can i get a better
i wanted to do a game show for veal or but i have no idea how to implement that i'm gonna
be doing my research over the next few ones but i wanted to do one about vein's brain rot
oh i will win so hard i was gonna make it that the prize is someone gets a 300
dollar skeb whoever wins what yeah or or you can just take the 300 dollars no i'm excited about
the skeb uh i will be winning that thank you very much well i thought i'd just need to figure out
how to do it right who we got we've got definitely not john i'll write your name down because you
have the chance to play and then for the other reef one or here i'm oh there he is sorry i do
apologize who we got we've got ruin this elation a little harlot it's funny because we've been
getting like a harlot in a reefling almost every time it's almost like we have a long call we
should just make out she be um we need ship art i need i need a saucy skeb of a strongy
and i say saucy we're just eating tomato soup that's it you know i'm awesome uh do you guys
talk do you want to bark want to bark for us huh you think emmy would win that no emmy would not
win because it is before her time she has to talk brain rot i have vine brain rot i hate that
was that in game or was that no those so they were talking are you yapping speak
how that's it one bark your turn we won't
come on is your mic broken we're gonna bully you a lot of their mics are broken
it might be how do you talk in game what i'm marie please i don't know how you talk
sorry must be oh no this microphone's broken right are we ready he's lying i don't i don't
believe him there's a hand coming through the door a little hand jobby oh i'm ready when you are
ready door has been opened door stuck let the you know let them go first you know
let them scope the area you know how it is and you tactical teams yeah actually i want to get
gun why do i still have this oh is uh whoever goes first i'll keep the shock yes
yeah this is a nice little road very quaint red lake district yeah i think they're you got a
tattooist you think they got uh girls oh it's called club d there's club do i have a deagle
what the fuck is this you play cs yeah you just play a lot of cs oh i have like over 600 hours
in vain forces i haven't played cs in a long time but if you're familiar with it i will play cs
with you strani i will play any game with you you know this i was getting nervous to ask because i
feel like i don't mind i don't have like plans of your own and like you just want to have till
week seven uh she was me uh she was me uh we just have a weekly stream together
on the roster forever now something's making big noise is that a witch or is this a i heard a
big girl it's just a girl here oh i heard a train uh that was a truck but it did sound like a train
for some reason that was very confusing oh it's called red flight to rubar cafe so i guess
yeah oh i felt like cs go lobbies right if we all shoot together right we could can the enemies
here isn't cs go oh no oh i thought we could like trash talk well technically in like lobbies yeah
okay um but because like you're against a team you usually can't hear the other team
yeah i forget there's no indian site i actually don't mean that there's no indian site in this game
yeah it's all like uh it's a lot of of course it's the same exact weapons because it's also
made in source um and it's usually like you have to like crouch and like do your like weapon spray
and there's i remember just freaking studying that for hours trying to get the rights like
pull down spray pattern shit here's someone somebody upstairs i hear him oh there he is oh
he's exploded in there um do we where do we go is this not uh no we came from here
wait we can oh i think you're going the right way there's a there's a heels
and oh no you're right we did come from that way
good thing that there is a first aid kit right here if you need literally did they drop that
did they drop the specials drop items no that was already there what is this
this is just a fence i have a what oh i would go up and say where oh yeah there's stairs
ventilation shaft can i get some money money money there's some money in there oh here it is
i was like how do we get up to the fire escape because i'm pretty sure that's where we go
ah oh this is like new york when they have all those fire escape things yeah
i don't know i have a shot past you oh stop exploring on your own
i don't even know how you were floating like that i was being hung on like the tongue
yeah that's a strong-ass tongue i've got explosive ammo
dinamite and must be italian
i have a bat so i'm gonna go back on the street
i don't know i don't know where we're going i'm just watching you out the window
where are you going sorry is this not where we're to go i don't know
it seems like it because there's new enemies that's when you know you're going
the right way and then there's no enemies lead up mm-hmm oh
there's no nowhere now i have a bio thing i don't know what this does
oh my god that why is she purple oh that was strange
very dark press if you turn on your flashlight
flashlight not to be confused with your son to be a fib
i wish i had a chainsaw oh where where oh what because the boomer i was confused
oh there's so many you should do a parody of okay boomer and it's okay boomie whatever you say
yeah oh my god that would be so cute that would be actually really cute oh that's actually a good
idea oh there's a wee epi pen in here i will take an adrenaline shot oh no i need to heal this reef
one hold on reefing needs it more than the reefing hero can heroine the they can the
yeah the harem link can heal themselves they have a heal i'm trying to stand up
uh okay we got it we were a bit occupied there's pipe bombs over here oh
oh
okay i'm stuck i'm pain what a unique enemy is it dead no come back if you're gonna lick me at
least let me kill oh yeah that's the one this the smoker is one that grabs you with the tongue
you know ah i don't know why
very i do like the enemies very uh yeah they're pretty cool definitely scary
um i don't like enemies that can grab you and i i like that it removes your ability to play
and tell your teammates help you yeah whole point is to play together oh Jesus scared me
that scared me
you didn't tell me first maybe you should be wearing my heart rate one or one
this is actually a horror game
it's when they come out of nowhere when you didn't expect it like you don't hear the audio cue
because there's so much going on yeah
sorry can you stop shooting me what is this poop water can i throw a molotov in it
when stagnant water is bad oh it works i don't know what is going on i hope you're okay though
i hope you're okay i don't know what's happening i just hope you're okay
it was nice knowing you like i just stuck up there jockey jockey
ain't this a joke get off my jock jockey oh i can't get up here i thought that was stairs
baby can i ask you something embarrassing of course what's the jock strap
oh i can't tell you because so i was like um a jock strap otherwise known as the banana hammock
i was uh i was looking at lingerie with the with the harlots in one of my streams
and we were looking at jock straps and i was trying it's like almost like a thong for men
oh yeah i took me a moment to think of what it was for a second
and i'm like you guys should buy them and then you know send pics you using the bedroom
i don't i think guys just wear them i think it's like the equivalent of like girls wearing a thong
right what do we do we jump oh i'm like girls right we wear thongs
you were closed
don't shake me don't shake me it's for sport usually the cup is in front oh for sports
i thought it was just like a male thong i didn't think it was like a cup thing
right keep moving keep moving up the ladder up the ladder up the ladder come on move up move
up move up the pool water i can't run to the safe room this fucking lady
ah i'm resisting where's the ladder go there it is
oh come on guys get up i'm fucking getting sun locked holy shit what's going on are they jumping
up and climbing like that i'm getting stunned all right i can move now yeah that was annoying
i was just getting stunned and still getting walloped right everyone's here everyone's here
right we're all here we're all here protect it's mostly related to sports oh oh there's more
i'm stuck oh my god uh hello you're being i'm being i'm trying to not hit you
i don't think there's friendly fire like actual damage so
uh i don't know because they see stop shooting well if i shoot you right now
your health is going down is it not no okay why do they pretend and i mean i guess maybe it's just
just like stop shooting each other
pardon me secret tunnel secret tunnel
oh my jesus christ oh what the fuck is this scary how did he just run past all of us
i um getting stun locks i can't see anything
i have a defib that's good because i know yeah i see ruin is on his last legs so yeah
we can make it come on of course a noxious acid is by the fucking ladder
ladder as all the zombies literally spawning oh this one is stuck i love glitches and
source uh right i'm nuking myself it's been lovely it's been lovely no really it's been an absolute
pleasure it's a new justice by the way oh hey there's health up here though hey uh her needs
the refling needs it more than me come by come back
done still you need it more than i do okay this dude is running away he ran into the safe room
how how did he run into the safe room that's so weird i'm just gonna get right now i'm healing
so hard right now oh i've healed so hard oh it feels so hard mother fuckers want to find me
oh we've got to close the door that's why
whipsies yeah no friendly fire on easy duct straps are sports equipment
these accusations that i only play games when easy mode are shocking i don't know where you're on
truly i don't know
i cannot get over how nice the weaponry feels in this game
what one would say a 10 out of 10 i reach through very highly
you're welcome thanks for barking i would like to see mercy and ic play this game
if you're like ic would just be screaming the entire time so would mercy
does mercy get motion sick in these games i probably anything park park this is so good
i've found it very hard to i can't figure out what games make mercy sick and not i think first
person she's okay and its third person is the problem oh i think if it's over the shoulder
and the camera isn't all focused then that's what gives her emotions like this
okay we got la bill
la bill and we got to reluctantly saying hello hello
you know what to do go on with a big
already comes pre-trained pre-trained
can you bar
bark bark
do i never heard of bark motherfucker
uh no don't say the word bark you have to go feral you have to you have to prove
how much we've corrupted you how much we've we've we've made we've groomed you okay do you
know how long it takes to groom you we've been at it for months now
oh you said hello you can
wait did he did he say it i think i think he went woof woof okay whatever i guess you're safe for
now label la bill if that's your real name yeah exactly okay he's not he's not and he did bark
i just didn't come through that well okay are we ready oh i didn't get right ready ready
all right let me let me in let me in
oh see there's people oh wait hello
why are you shooting
let's keep the humans alive
i'm just a little banged up is your leg fucking broken brother i i think he's bitten and he's
hating it he's hating it do you want to come along with us the left for dead one crew is it
oh that's funny i didn't know that i thought i recognized them that's cool okay
oh so the left for dead two takes off where the other team finished that's so cool we love continuity
in sequels with new players new battle wizard money gang we love sequels that are actually sequels
you'll need missing one person no we're not we are all here i think i think they're fourth
perished in life for dead one oh at least there's ammo right here oh no i'm being ridden
oh i was shooting a human oh so was i it's look we're a bit used to just sprain and
pray and do forgive us but sorry about that last sorry sorry it's just a bit of a misunderstanding
oh we gotta get gas cans okay we gotta do this gas can retrieval thing again jesus christ
where is the closest
yeah you're never gonna fill up the generator
where can i get to this generator i mean this gas can
burn oh that's over here go away this looks suspiciously like a massive trap
and i'm not sure don't be suspicious oh don't be the smoker
oh i found a katana don't mind if i do katana wins oh she's named after sharp weapon because
she has sharp weapons oh my gosh i didn't know i didn't know oh i keep getting fucking stuck
this is not the easiest map we've put oh yeah i'm getting fucking pinned again thank you for
saving me oh i feel good oh i don't have better i'm doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it it was
worth it it's been lovely it really has where are you i'm fucking you can i always just do
molotov cocktail why are these tanks so spread out oh my god
it's throwing a slab of concrete at me
what i wish i could see but i'm far away pick up the floor and throw it
it she's slow wait
was that that's a bit dramatic for a zombie don't you think
good great question nick why doesn't anything have enough gas in it
oh thank you did you know that during a real zombie apocalypse that going for gasoline isn't
the smartest thing to do because it doesn't have good preservation yep there's no point
because it usually did you know that it's most likely that seeds will be a very high commodity
to grow your own food will become farmers again if a zombie apocalypse really happened
i watch the walking dead i get it i watch the i watch the what do you need help i'm helping i'm
helping oh you're getting you're getting caught oh i'm getting caught too hold on a minute let me
pick you up
i have a defib
oh i have a heal kit oh what the fuck oh um well it's awkward we can't hurt each other i'm spraying
and praying i'm being beaten up oh i'm helping i'm helping oh there's a thing back there where you
uh i think uh can i defib myself uh who are you fibbing you can't defib yourself
can i defib you uh oh i fell in my own gas can i defib you oh wait you're not dead dead so
doesn't matter i'm not dead yet okay i was trying to get you and i got attacked by something
oh god this is but why is this map so hard did i make it normal did i not make this easy
i mean super different expert mode oh where is this fucking smoker smoker that got me
we literally i was gonna say we literally cannot see can someone pick up okay i got him
i'm killing his audience around him fucking gas can i get him we'll be like got you i'm covering
i have one health why did i miss the level let's go down
oh my god there's two there's three what what happened what was that uh did that
oh
is that supposed to happen
it literally i told you i was playing legendary mode and none of yous believed me that just not
yours it's so easy no it doesn't i just have you tab this is easy
no i wish i had that defib still oh
so no no no no we never got to win you have to win no you have to win
you have to stay you're not allowed to leave until we win
it doesn't count that's not how it works right okay so what did i do i lost my katana
no i prefer the assault rifle i'm in a assault rifle gal i'm in a assault rifle gal all right
i'll talk to these goofballs again okay hey i guess harder the more gas cans you get so you
better see put them in just grab the cans and put them to the side okay the caller stays on until
mommy wins exactly that's right okay right i won't put any gas in the generator but we'll we'll get
our stocks up our stonks will be super duper high the highest stonks normally they're locked in with
must be terrible literally you're forced to stay away i don't care if you've got work you've got
responsibilities yeah of course we are not leaving take priority i will take this pipe bomb thank you
very much okay all right so i guess just bring them and bring them i keep doing that right don't
do that she's a nice lady she did she's protecting me where is wow we went down no that was like
overwhelming okay there's that one all the way over here i can grab okay one two and then we just
put them all in it once that makes sense very gently right right that's a horde sound so i'm
going to purposefully stay behind with the npcs until the horde sound goes away because i'm not
getting shagged for that why am i on fire because you're feeling hot hot hot you're so on fire
did i accidentally blow up the gas can that i had can you do that will it respawn i think i did it
it respawned it respawned okay okay okay all right i need to make sure we're doing
wait wait wait don't put them in don't put them in don't put them in if you put them in it makes
it harder no yeah we're leaving them out here just gather them and then drop them in here nearby
you're too efficient refling and harlots you're too efficient harlings harlings
okay that's what five cans right i'm gonna go get one more i think that we
horde noises over wherever that was i'll grab that there's something big stomping around what
fuck oh yep oh katana don't go for me
why there's so many special ones over here oh Jesus
right oh you grabbed it okay wait there's a smoke cart oh it must have something spent in
bail and it's not me for once they all just like burst out of a fucking room okay that
buses killer thank you gaming kitsu ni for being a member
oh oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no oh no no no no i can't continue
all right i'm coming back okay i'm coming i'm not gonna make it i can't go on me you can
closer closer well I let I believe in you you can do it I promise you can
continue on with that I couldn't make it it's hard okay I feel better thank you
for that oh perfect nice oh what the frick girl is another jockey or hunter
rather oh ragdoll was great that day all right let's find oh I don't know where's
our body where are you I can't see wait open the defibrillators and there'll be
a red dot where he is on the map if you have the defibrillators I do I don't see
a red dot did you just found it my found him I found him help help help help help
help help help help I'm right in front of you hold on I mean that it right I'm
gonna go pick up more ammo very selfishly I hear specialists of course
spit yeah I'm gonna fit right I'm gonna go pick up more and I never thought
about that did you blow the gas can oh my god oh my god I did not just do that
to us sorry I can't believe I just at least they respond let's do I'm MLG and
I want to do we're walking in we're walking right fucking it just put the
cans in the fucking thing cuz I'm gonna end up doing that again I can just see
it I honestly can I think what it was is maybe we were being attacked by a
horde cuz oh there's a smoker I can't see I'm coming okay I got it got it and
and and and and and spray and pray spray and pray pipe bomb pipe bomb I can't
believe it that that right I'm staying next to the AI cuz they'll cover us a
see you okay okay and there's right there see next there's a horde coming so
prepare if you want to stay next to the AI I'm staying here with AI and then that
horde passes and then we'll go for more okay I'm already far away
are they this is fucking kid
and turn what camera can right oh there's a freaking thing humping me hold
on hold on hold on what is happening I don't know if I'm helping or making it
worse hold on I'm coming oh you're in the smoke oh okay I got you back I got
you back I got you back baby I got you back yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay I'm
someone else no no no no I'm reloading I'm reloading
stay with the AI stay with the AI I don't have any ammo what the fuck I hear
here on the floor next to the cons oh my gosh how can you de-fib him oh my god
I don't have a de-fib anymore it's a one time oh as if it's already out of
frickin stonk okay okay right again stay with the AI the AI will protect us I
have a heel for you sheepsters oh no oh my god oh my god oh my god I'm staying
with AI let them do the billet spree in oh no sorry charger charger more like
deader dude yeah got him oh no see another word not I'm not moving out for a
can and where is it which way they're here I have a pipe bomb I don't and gave
an explosion okay there we go oh sorry I'm shooting you awkward okay right now
we can move out oh my god why is this so hard did I miss a memo or something no
right now we can move out I suppose let's move out together all balls roll out no
we got him stay together right stay together like glue I'm sticking with you
we gotta get those other cans though oh I'm on the wrong side oh I know there's a
staircase here don't you worry there's a we stayed case I'm on it I'm coming up
the stairs okay and then we'll pick up this can and then you pick the can up to
and then we'll go right back to the start and then that's two extra cans oh
he's being grabbed
I'll grab this oh god this another word okay oh I'm gonna go bring you general digression oh my
god
Things areiran-sing, no-rezi, no-rezi.
Oh no!
On!
That was jockey.
Oh, gosh.
What is this add?
My arena is yelling in the background.
No, great, Serena.
I like rainhua.
You got a good idea.
that's how much I've been spraying and praying. I can't see. I can't see. I'm fucking bringing the
cat over. This is outrageous. Come into the AI. Come into the AI. I'm trying. And there's ammo too.
Okay, there should be, sometimes they just rode. There's med kit spawned. I see one right. Let me
heal. Let me heal. Let me heal. Let me heal. Let me heal. Let me heal. No, I was gonna, oh, are we?
Oh,
no, put the pan away. Put the pan away. I'm freaking taking it. Oh,
I didn't put away. Right. Right. Up you come. Up you come.
Right. This is so funny. And then peel and she be right. And then I'm going to heal
this neighbor right. And then I'm going to get the fucking gun and put it in the fucking thing.
Come here. Right. I'm going to pick up extra ammo as well. Because I lost ammo. I don't know who
got to get the pills too. Okay, I picked up ammo. I'm an assault rifle. We need four more cans. I'm
fine. I'm fine. Honestly, that didn't hurt that much. Okay, I'm gonna take adrenaline. Fuck it.
Wait, you actually shoved shit in your leg. Oh my god, something is going on really weird.
Right. Oh, I took adrenaline. I took a pill and I be saw. I didn't sometimes.
The NPCs will throw more stuff at us to help. I'm wishing they would throw something.
Can you guys throw down some like bombs? My adrenaline war off and I'm slow again.
And there's another horse. I can swing my sword to the heart. I'm taking.
Right. No, fuck you. Get back to the AI. Get back to the AI. Get back to the AI.
I'm just hanging out with the AI right now. I'm not going to lie. There's so many.
Can you make it replaying? Okay. I'm trying so hard. Okay, I'm back in range. I'm back in range.
I have a can. A smoker. So that didn't, we did good. Okay, we did good. There is a smoker. I don't know where
we. Okay, three more. Three more. Okay, I'm off. I got the high ground Anakin.
Oh, my nose is bulking. Why is it leaking? Hold on.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he's down. He's down. You need to find some help and take it.
No. Use me as cannon fodder. Right. I've got the next can.
I'm off. I'm going to follow your back.
I'm with the AI. No, no. Go with him. Go with him because I've got the AI covering me now.
Hurray! He has a can. He's got the can.
Okay. Oh, charger. How did it get me? Okay. Help. Thank you.
I'm fucking gaming. Oh, I'm gaming so hard right now. One more. One freaking more and we're done.
We never have to play this level again. Are you done healing? You see it across this fucking map?
I'm literally the very last one. Maybe we should, oh, maybe you should start with the far away ones.
Now that I think about it. Yeah, I'm getting closer. Oh, shit. Okay, we're doing okay. We're doing okay.
We're doing okay. We're locked in. Should we go for it? No, yeah. No, yeah. No, yeah. I don't know if it's over.
Oh, you're right. Oh, that's where that fucking thing was. I was trying to find that thing. Okay.
What? Oh, god. We didn't even get out before the next one came.
Oh. Oh, come on. Okay. Okay, boomer. Oh, I keep that. That's it. No, right. Fucking go. Move out. Move out.
Move out. No, don't move out. Don't move out. I'm right. I'm fine. Come to Main Street. Come to Main Street.
Come to Main Street. Main Street. I'm here. I'm here. I'm here. Not right. Okay. It really is.
You need to take the one furthest away. Keep going. Keep going. Keep going. Okay. Remember,
we can shoot through each other. It's fine. I can't fucking see shit. Right. I'm getting it.
I'm getting it. I'm getting it. I've got it. I've got it. I've got it. I'm fucking beating up a zombie
with it. But I got it. It's fine. It's fine. I'm beating up everything. I'm making my way down.
There's fire. Watch out. Oh, how?
I'm not playing this map again. I'm not playing again.
She just went up. No. I literally, I refuse to put your glory in.
I'm fine. I'm not playing this lower faster. Please don't make me the last one left.
Right. It's okay. It cannot come. It's small means cannot comprehend the chain link fence.
Okay. Okay. Oh, I'm being stopped on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
Hurry to the rescue vehicle. I would love to. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on. Come on.
I'm away. We're not playing this again. Yeah. We just got left.
What's wrong? He just left us. I left three dead.
Oh, literally. That was not. That was hot.
Don't die. The passing because we all died. Disease, disease, disease.
Oh, I was so sorry. The sole survivor. I'm not playing that map. That was awful.
Oh, that was horrible. That was so hard for no reason.
So, so hard. Stranny left for death.
Yeah. I didn't want to play that again. So honestly, thank God. Yeah.
You're actually playing this level again later. No. No. We're doing the 4v4.
We're doing the 4v4 shenanigans. I can right click to shove. I know. Will I use it? No.
Exactly. You tell him. No, we will now do the 4v4 thing. I don't know what it is.
So, you're going to have to tell me how to get into overall accuracy as if I have the highest
accuracy. Fifteen percent. Let's go. Do not believe that first thing.
Wow. Awesome. Yes. Never ending. Did my game just crash? No. Okay. Right.
I just heard. And then that was it. Right. Okay. Let us analyze. So, if I want to do this 4v4 thing,
I would like to... Bye, guys. Thanks for playing. Thank you very much for playing.
What? Verses? Verses. Verses. Play as a survivor infected in an online match. Okay.
Play with friends? Yes. Play on Steam group server? No. Play with friends.
Create a new Verses lobby. Okay. Left click to gun. Thanks, guys.
And then...
Wait. We stop you trying to win the campaign?
Yeah. We got to try to kill him. I want to be a zombie.
Server type. Official dedicate. Create lobby. Right. Don't bomb yet. Not until Sheepsters is in.
That's not fair. Let Sheepsters come in. I said, don't bomb it.
Where are you? I'm in. Oh, okay. Right. Sheep is a little bomb. Right. And if you did play
previously, please don't do the honor system. Right. So, let me write down the names. No one special.
That's not a nice thing to call yourself. You're very special. I know. I thought that every time.
You need to be earful with your words because you'll start thinking it's true. If you put it
into existence, you'll start willing that. Okay. Noob, Lore, John, Omni, Battler.
Battler? Yeah, Battler.
She's like the bat.
Nihongo. Right. Okay.
Right. So, choose character.
Can you guys pick if you're the goodie or the baddie? Wait. What do you want me and Sheep?
I want to be a zombie. Right. I'm gonna pick coach. Put me in coach. Right. And then can you
guys choose character or don't you choose character for you? I can be infected. Okay.
If you select infected, you'll do that. Just do, I guess, random. You can pick a side.
And then whoever's left will get randomized, I assume, when we start the game.
Can I go for a very quick tinkle? I actually need a tinkle.
I'll keep you occupied. Give me uno momento, por favor.
Literally, my toilet's right there, so.
She just pees. It's like a little cuddle fish litter box.
I want to be quiet. I'm trying to hear Stronny P.
I don't hear anything. This is a bummer.
I can't wait to be a zombie.
You mean my mouth?
She be coming to get the hire links? Yep.
She be in Harlow's versus Stronny. You're really full. You guys watch both of us, so.
Sweet gaslight. No, you guys do that to me all the time. I hate it. It freaks me out.
So how are you guys doing? Hello, welcome in. We're playing Left 4 Dead. I'm sorry,
I'm a little bit quiet and low energy because of my head horde.
Exactly, boomie. I don't know if you guys heard boomie in the background just then.
Hi, what's up, boomie?
Well, my confirmed two steps ahead.
Hello, Mr. Boomer Team. Head improving at all? No, and I don't know why.
What's up, boomie? You're just here because there's food on my desk.
Boomie, try to steal my mozzarella sticks.
Boomie, you can't have this food.
Not to get political or anything, but the amount of piss that just came out of me.
I was trying to listen. I was listening real close.
You're not wearing. I was like, everybody's shh. We should be able to hear.
It's shocking. Right. What's the agendination?
The agendination?
I'm not beating the P.O. of the relegation. As soon as it does that, I'm dropping mine,
and then you can all, you can put a compilation of all our P's together.
And just listen to it on repeat. Instead of listening to like one hour of rain to put
yourself to sleep, it's just one hour of piss. Oh, that'd be a good idea.
Blue bar piss sounds. Come on. And we put it up as a freebie on everybody's Patreon. Come on.
Oh, no, you're actually not allowed to put on Patreon. You're allowed to put on YouTube,
strangely enough. Right. As soon as the hit start game is going to do the,
it's going to randomize the rest. So if the other snipers aren't bothered,
we'll just jump right into it and let's get started. Now, obviously,
first things first. Unexpectedly based. I'm so based.
So I'm going to make a remix of the audios, what you want to dance and listen to a song of our
tinkles getting. Oh, guess the piss. So you have to guess who's peeing.
That's actually really funny. Who's piss is this?
How did the vain one that comes out of vain? If we do a real game show,
I'm fucking doing that kind of content. We're asking you guys about the content that all the
gen mates of me take. Can you identify whose tinkle this is?
That sounds like Frank chicken. That's definitely strong.
Damn, Frank chicken in there. Oh, no, seriously.
Okay, so I have me in the game. I have to choose a spawn location.
I don't. So you can come at me. Oh, this is fun.
Oh, boy.
So are you just like a regular schmagular zombie or sure you stream guest there.
Oh, wait, P you guess or stream. That's a good. Sorry, I messed up your thing.
I'm just coughing the entire time.
Oh, why do I cough so much?
I can hear them. They're making they're like coming for you.
Oh, yeah, actually. I'm Friday. How can I tell who it is? Just when the NPCness stops, I guess.
I can't walk through this. Oh, I think it's a wall. Come closer.
I can literally hear something grumbling in the woods.
Is that you, Shibi? Are you lurking around? No. Are you grumbling?
I hear it. Oh, oh.
Oh, so you have to please specialize zombies against us. Oh, my God. Oh, I died. Dang it.
What? Oh, my God. Killed a sheebie. Yeah, I like this. This is so good.
Right. It's fun. I just grabbed you with my little tongue.
Grabbing harlots with your tongue. Are you?
I love that we can stick our tongues out on our muscles. Oh, gosh, what did I spawn as?
Oh, is that like randomized zombie spawn as well? Yeah, it seems so.
I can't spot. I'm getting on me. I don't know what it is, but knock it off. I can't see anything.
I literally cannot see a damn thing. It's green.
Oh, I'm getting my ass beat. I'm getting my ass beat. Holy shit. I can climb stuff.
What? I hate shotguns. Oh, someone got me. I love you. I died.
How we killed any of them? Well, I suppose it's not supposed to be balanced like MPC balance.
Who needs heels? I'm killing myself. Okay, we hate the Shrek vision. Honestly, welcome to
the survivors. We have to like stop you from like moving forward. Oh, yeah, because I recognize
this from the, um, okay. Yeah, boomer and bail. Oh, thank God. Give me that. Hold on. I'm going UNP.
Can be seen by the survivors.
Oh, I see that. Who's that? Is that what he is? I got you. I saw you. I saw you creeping around.
I hear. Oh, nice. You got me. You got me. I don't know who that is. You fucking got me.
How did I just die? I got killed in one hit. You have very low HP, but I suppose because
you can keep coming back to get us. Yeah, that's true. I can't see shit. I cannot see a single thing.
I'm just happy to be here. Honestly. This is really fun. Just like being an evil zombie.
Evil. I can't believe it. He's watching. Watching,
watching teammates try to kill you guys is kind of funny.
I don't know what you see, but I'll try I'll be in it. I'll be an evil zombie next one
Just so I can see what it looks like
No, I thought that was a real player. It was just a regular zombie. Ah, I hear you. Oh, no, I
Hear you I hear you I gotta get close to you. Oh no, I'm gonna die
Can I go faster? What is this? Damn it. Hunter sucks
You want to watch where you're shooting?
What hold on and reloading
Get a second pistol why?
Mustang and set entering spawn mode. What am I?
Oh
Okay, I'm a spitter
There's a wit
Does it get removed cuz we're playing versus month
Trying to find a good place to spawn
Call me Lara Crofts cuz goddamn I got jubilee a pistol looks really cool
What takes a huh
Oh
This kills me
Well, I have to wait for my primary attack to come back
Well, okay, you just stand in there taking all the shots like come on
Why am I spitting on you guys again? I like the spitter. I'm hawk to win. I'm hawk to Ananya
We can't hurt each other, right? I never I don't think so cuz it's on easy mode. Uh, there's temporary health here
I'll give it to
Watch I mean coach for me in oh
The way whoa, this is a hard one to be as but I'll make it work
Yeah, we're gonna we're just we're just gonna pop
Oh, I can't spawn here damn it you guys are so close we can't even fucking spawn
Wait, it's not it doesn't let you spawn. Yeah, cuz you guys are right next to us. Oh
Wow
Okay
I'm getting fucking shag. I'm not gonna lie. I can't see a single fucking thing going on. I
Wish I was a I hope I spawn back in as a boomer
So
That's a pitbull concert right now mean you're let's go
And I'm like honestly that's really good I like that I like that detail
Where are they they're they're gonna be in the ambitious
I can't get I'm stuck
Okay, now I'm not I was a good spray
Oh fuck
Yeah
Yeah, I was being a little goblin
We're in trouble, I'm not gonna lie. We're in trouble you guys
May be able to do this. We are not in very good shape right now. Oh
Perfect
Are very poor right now. I love this part of the map
Can I be seen do we go keep going here
Lots of goodness we have to claim we go down the hell yep, I guess whoa
I'm fucking spraying and praying. Oh damn it. They saw me
Should I just ran you didn't
frustrating if we like instantly kill you that's a little bit. Yeah
Probably you're gonna hear me screaming in the next round
That's enough. Are we supposed to be able to like to kill you all at the same time and then we win
Our health is definitely getting low like don't think you're not doing anything like we're getting fucked up over here
We've not had any so please don't
What was your plan oh
They're cut. Yeah. Yeah, this is what we didn't want. I'm getting fucking shagged
No, I'm not gonna make it. I'm not gonna make it. Oh
My god
I
Got it
We need to feel so badly
Get out literally we are so perfect nifty now we're
Hard to find a way to replace a spawn
Anyway
I'm sprained because you guys are sprained
Are you real
Okay, I'm not too far away
Oh
Frick I thought that's my teammate
There's a spare six o'clock done the hill no
Creeping around with your little green tongue back there
Oh
Please I can't take any more. I'm done
Run to the end run to the end
Oh my god
Okay, right we're gonna back out to give other people a chance is wait, can you guys leave and like get sniped?
There's him or do you want we should I don't know I feel like both ways is gonna take yeah
I think I'll take too long
Can you guys leave and then others can try and come in I
Don't see you play
Thank you very much GGs. Thank you
Yeah, they're leaving thank you
So you guys can still snipe or do you need to be in the lobby I don't know
Can anyone stream snipe
Can't spawn here. Oh wait, hold on. Oh, no, no, it's working as whoa
That he could do and stash and okay, okay good. I'm waiting on and I got blank
Quiet boys
I've got zero
And then here you go you've got
I got blank a blank name. There's no name
Stash and Hikaru
I've got a slot for wait, there's someone without a name. Yeah, literally no, no, no, well
I guess we'll call you peaches puke because it was like peaches
Just puke and then no name in bracket. All right, let's let's move up move up gentlemen
Have chaotic
Clone oh
They just freaking came out of nowhere
Here can be seen by survivors press primary attack charge. I'm getting killed by normal
or oh
What?
Okay, I understand I am I comprehend what were to do
The trick is to use snipers really I feel like snipers are so hard to deal with
Well, probably just spot them from farther away
Just like there's not much in the chamber
All right, so I need to back away right, okay
Am I in
Oh
No, no, I knocked them down, but I never killed
I was like a little leap I'll go and left and right. I'm like yeah, my pink's protecting me. You can't shoot me
I'm stuck
Oh my ping is literally I am lagging
Leap over the same one again right I can do that I
Can hear one of them just
I love this
I'm coming for you. Oh
My god, that's so good. I was like jumping like a horse or like a frog and you're gonna get you what the hell
This shotgun sucks or it definitely can't spawn here
Oh my god, the lag is killing me
That boomers are quite hard to play I'm not sure they're the most effective. You literally just have to run
Play your your bomb gets on them. Yeah, no, don't worry friends. It's okay. Mommy's don't play
Well, he won't let me
Picklings rejoice the boomers rage
Thank you for the heels. Oh
Let's spawn here can be seen by survivors. Okay. No
No, I can't get up back up there. Oh
No, I kind of know how to get back up there to get to him ah sugar
Missed that one up. I got confused. I thought it was the other zombie
Someone's getting decimated down there
That's me. It's I don't know. I will we might die sooner than the other guys
I'm supposed to be on the enemy team, but I want you to have fun though
I don't want it to be like oh, oh, so you want to play with us. She's just wanna you
You want to make us last a little bit longer for amusement
I don't want it to be like oh, we're gonna overwhelm take fun. You know that is the part of the fun
Play with your food honestly, yeah, I'm getting a few licks and so the jockey. It's a jobby
Oh
There's a witch careful
Don't wake her up. I don't know where she is. I couldn't figure out what yeah, that's where stash power
Somebody oh, he's okay. It's my never tongue. Oh and well, right, okay. Oh
Charger oh
I got you I got you
Ah tough frick. Oh my god
Is there is there okay pills, oh
Please someone's blimpin someone doesn't feel good
The em
I get a new fucking weapon
I love the tongue snarl
Oh, I see someone coming I see someone coming
Mommy with a smoker if you tongue someone from a ledge you can hang them and kill them. Oh, yep. Am I?
It's so violent though. Okay. We got to go through the frickin
Only wake up a bit
Oh one of them
But not the worst part to be arch and claw, right? Okay. Oh, I'm stuck
Yeah, because I turned her
Oh, shit
Oh, no. Oh my god
Uh, oh
Yeah, I was gonna I didn't want to ruin the fun, but
I can't get down that was I can't get down
Oh my god
Can't spawn here something is blocking. Oh, I'm stuck
Oh, no, I've glitched out. I can't see
Oh
Set fire. Oh my god
We just got destroyed
I'm coming I'm coming yet. No!
That was good. It's hard. Yeah. That was good
I mean they cut cut cut cut cut
What does Rena screaming about hold on that was farm. That was good. That was so good
You have more for it?
Uh
right we'll do new lobby you will play survivors in the next chapter no don't put me in the next
chapter we're safe for now yeah everyone did so well thank you right i'm going to wait
how are we still in right for those of you that played please swap out you can add me on steam
i'm just running so if you've had a shot please swap
unless we're already on the honor system there's a few people that have not had a shot yet
you just snipe me in game
what is making that noise
there's something screaming
i'm doing it
no no no you're fine you're fine uh right we have
i got diddy head empty no thoughts and wyzen
i'm just running everyone's name though this is a restricted area
come on leave leave the room wait i'm right down the name
i need to be nice to make sure that everyone gets a chance i wanted a chance
didy
uh i don't want a shotgun take the med kit though right let's do it
let's do it let's do it
all right they're coming i don't know where they're coming but they're coming all right
they're there they're there someone's here someone's here
that's a horde is hard enough to try and win again it's like the regular one
i've been grabbed how dare you release me my time was broken this person took a long time to kill me
hi serenity we're on the bridge
catch your knee
i serenity lord they're coming serenity did you know about the hit video game left for dead too
it's a really good game it's a really good game i would get to play it for the first time to do
with shibi and the reeflings and the harlots it is such a good game i cannot recommend it enough
i hope your donor thong's going well as well
as your first time yeah i've never played it before
and until today and now i forever have the whoo the loving memory that i got to play this game
for the first time with shibi and i almost kill somebody
sorry i'm watching both povs
hi serenity she's on my channel yeah this is really fun this would be good for like a big
collab with um oh my god yes oh my god yes big v-shipper collab
oh actually it could be 3v3 for a feeler
you always said thank you but never bark
oh the frick you guys showed up before i could spawn
okay where are they where are they where are they they're trained well they're trained well
oh there's a chainsaw i'm to go oh enemies enemies enemies enemies hold on you reload
there's a spare where's the chainsaw
oh yeah
where's the chainsaw i love being like enemies i can't see nothing oh i'm getting
back off right i don't like this gun because it's not a it's a burst fire and we don't
like burst fire in this house we want to be able to perish all enemies in the nearest
next viewer collab is left for dead no it's gonna be uh i know what i'm asking for
my next viewer collab because uh yeah i think it's really not gonna be this game at all
it'll be it'll be gary's mod first and then
sorry i still can't figure out where the frick this chain killer is chainsaw killer thingy
i'm trying to do my primary attack it's not working that doesn't make any sense to me
i can't leap who have who have chainsaw
i see it oh my god it's funny because you can see the silhouettes of your teammates and like in
and you can i can see how close they are to you but you guys don't know about it
oh you're really injured no one has a head cut uh uh count kiss we can you heal um her i don't
know her in character name p you have a med kit on your persons so uh stand still where are you going
come get healed
oh
okay this
oh i need to sneeze
no no stop it i'll sit up up look up look up
oh
i was hoping i'd get the smoker to do that
this is hard this is not easy
pulled out
what is going on hold on i'm reloading
oh my god we're not gonna make it we are not gonna make it we are not gonna make it i'm done
they got me
there is no way absolutely no way we're gonna make it out alive i'm one hp i'm literally limping
i can use adrenaline fuck it give me that shit oh oh oh perfect
changing oh i'm bringing
okay there we go
tactical shotgun no fuck that rail let's make it let's make it 25 percent of the way at least
how about that deal we'll make it to at least 25 percent of the way
avoid the gas uh i'm in it i'm in it i'm in it oh i have to wait to get my attack back
that's what it is no no no no stop pinging us off the ledge you guys are getting far too good
at this game far too far no
got me from the bail i spell help from the
absolutely rolled i can't believe it so let's see if we can get farther
good luck thank you for playing good luck good luck
okay let me check this friend request
okay there we go
okay uh we'll get new players and no it's tab i want to do new players new players go go go
you miss streamsnap at will my streamsnap account is just called strongy snaps
me god damn rabies
he got them rabies me i'm getting good well i'm in my element i'm a creature creature of the
night except now i'm just a i'm a black woman again i'm a freak i'm a weird okay i got god
damn rabies uh keks and alivia's alivia's alivia's alivia's aloha mora
i jumped oh my god look at alivia versus profile picture on steam can you see it in the tab let me
look at ryan gossler oh that's so cute there's a harem that has a u as a noodle oh no
that's so cute right you ready let's go let's just let's do this boys we got this first
show them no mercy okay we can we can't spawn yeah no you can't spawn in here
no no like it says because you've got pov when you're like whatever
okay they're just clearing up that's fine
no i missed no you didn't see that that's embarrassing you didn't see that i was like i'm
gonna get him i'm gonna get you oh he's gonna look behind us because you guys like to spawn behind
this oh there you are oh somebody's in the room oh the room oh drywall buncher what a very specific
name well you made a oopsie what am i a pounce hunter okay i can do that yeah the ping is kind of
trash yeah i mean honestly who's holding the ship
can i wait can i snake let me try with the hunting rifle oh what what's happening here
we're ganging up on you no no scope i'm coming for you ryan gossler i'm going ryan i'm going ryan gossler
oh i forgot i can't scope in
i got him i got him oh i have to do this to scope that's so weird no we need to jump she
no you don't i'm coming i see you look at you looking all cute and innocent there get away
from me i'm touching you right now in shadow form i'm waiting i'm waiting to get jumped on from
no you got protected you got protected
incendiary ammo where you need it 25 percent of the way there come on zombies we must up our game
uh make sure you look up top
oh yeah in case i'm creeping around up there coming for you yeah yeah
oh you should look behind yourself right now you'll never get i'm scared oh they're coming behind
behind doing fucking collars i couldn't see i'm touching you i'm touching your hair your
shoulders are getting yellow shoulder massage right there
oh what the heck has killed my draw almost got my drive all muncher
oh he's getting further than us oh no come on we must we must upper game we must be
evil zombies think evil think evil evil evil
i'm just no scoping no i can't do anything i did one spit and i was out i was gone yeah you
have to wait for it to the cooldown i can't believe it doesn't just let me spit all the time oh shocking
shong oh they're creeping around oh someone's limping we need to pick off the weakest one first
just a grenade don't you the tongue snarl okay how'd i go up oh
which way do we go this way
can you guys slow down i spawned at a really bad location
he's gonna go too fast for me hold on a minute i'm probably gonna
god this fucking like naded me that was like a nature yeah cuz i went out of that
they're gonna come down from the ladder
oh frick can i reload faster okay i should probably stay with oh i gotta go up you guys
make it up going up like so easy
i don't know what to do right they're up i see them up but how did i go upper than up you know
i feel it
oh
i can swing my soul i think you're almost there i think you're 50 of the way there we are you
may be able to do it you're a bit damaged but just a bit i think it's the actual normal mpc
zombies or what's really getting us everyone looks green on my end maybe it's not showing no yeah no
it doesn't show it like cuz i'm i'm literally close to death right now oh great okay i take it
sorry um uh probably you thought i'm down oh wait no yeah when you're the monster you can't
really see the accuracy of the health oh my god okay already dead they all ganged up on us at the
same fucking time we were waiting to spawn it's like a really awkward location
i'm such a bully i don't have anything to fucking go i'm almost out of ammo
this struggle snuggle yeah you want to struggle snuggle i'll give you somebody have any
anybody got help oh thanks brother you can give struggle snuggles oh what the
she's right oh koochi
i don't really like this character controversial but this zombie sucks
is this gonna work thank you so much i appreciate that because i know you're close to death
they all waited
they fucking waited holy whoa that was pretty good that was pretty good there was a wall
where we could climb up from behind that was like pure cheatcy diddles that was always that was very
smart are we sharing the same thing without us just rod brother rod run run to the end of your
hand because we're gonna come get it we see you oh no that i think that's it i think that's it
okay
oh damn it's so hard gg though gg ggs so m and g pro can't believe it
all right that was my last one i'm gonna go lay it down because of my i got ahead of it
yes please rest thank you so so much you be the uh genuine whole heart of the unit when i feel
like this this is so fun and unironically i'm going to carry this your association with this game
like for the rest for the rest of my life because i'll always be like oh that was the game mean
she played our first it's not like our first yeah like those with the reflames and the hair
thank you so so but thank you i love you so much strani i love you so much
okay bye guys bye
all right
it's not just gonna be me and you this is me is the strani still in there
give strani a kiss before i leave
hello
where's my where's my bedroom feels like poking me and tapping me on the arm
what's up
he's on pets i think
well i'm gonna say bye to you guys hold on
i had a lot of fun thank you guys so much i would i literally i'm so mad because i really
wanted to play like literally all day with strani and i'm pissed because of my headache
um i'm gonna go lay down and i'm gonna go sleep and he'll do this again yeah and then me and
strani have another street we have another collab we'll be playing portal together um hopefully
i can survive portal because i know i get motion sick with that game because all the like switching
povs in the switching of like it like it makes my head go crazy um and like upside down and
jumping through portals and so me and strani want to try to beat the whole game if i can survive
if i can survive um great chemistry yeah no strani strani strani is awesome i love strani
so much she's she's she's a bestie um it's always so fun i'm just so happy we actually got to play
on stream together one on one um but it's also it's it's kind of poetic that the first time me and
her have a collab it's also with you guys because i think it's just like we both just really value
our fan bases our audience our viewers so much and i'm kind of happy we got to share that with
you guys um yeah i liked me as a zombie yeah strani is really funny um please of course check
out strani she's the one who created me she is my mother she is she is the the mad scientist behind
vealer um so please of course if you're new and you just uh somehow discovered me through you know
i don't know algorithm or something please check her out um it was really fun it was really cute
i was really i almost cried when she was just like i'm going to associate this play through
this game with you guys um with with me uh and i'm happy that she can have that nice core memory
and i think i will tuck that away in my little memory box as well it was very very sweet indeed
i'm very thankful to have someone like strani in my life that gave me a chance and now we're
wonderful friends within vealer uh she is very sweet she tries her best and she wants what's
best for everyone and she's she's just a great person to work with not only a great person
to work with but just a great friend she always checks in on me and stuff and make sure that i'm
okay um always always if i need anything she will she's the first person to be by my side and um
uh ask me what i need so strani is a real one i love her to death uh i'm not crying you're crying
i am tearing up a little bit as i it's very rare you find um like i i'm very thankful that i have
found like true friends through v tubing like marie and tomah and chai and strani is there um of
course is the rest of my gen mates um but yeah she takes care of everyone very very well
yeah they're tears of joy i'm just so thankful to have um to have the opportunity to work with
and you know meet her and you just hang out with her um today was a great day yeah enemies back
dubs all around uh hopefully that it wasn't like a fluke though i don't want to like prematurely
celebrate but i'm just i'm hoping that it's a a thing because um and they hadn't done anything
with the appeal yet so maybe they just i don't know um but yeah yeah uh i will see you guys
what's today tomorrow what am i playing tomorrow let me take a peek
oh tomorrow is wednesday today is wednesday oh i have the day off tomorrow and then friday um
i'll do an asmr i'm gonna try to clean tomorrow and if i clean and i get everything that i need
to get done although i have to write the scripts too i might do a gorilla for elden ring who knows um
um we'll see i i gotta get those those scripts done i still haven't written any of the other ones
yet and i need to record them uh because i want to get them done uh by the 15th so i don't have to
yeah i want to do productive thursday um yep so i'll do that tomorrow i gotta clean i gotta clean
litter boxes i gotta clean the floor i gotta back up maybe i'll probably do a space tomorrow
because you guys generally you guys actually help me stay focused when i am cleaning so
i will probably try to do a toyerspace again while i clean i have to have dishes dishes sitting in
my sink for like two weeks uh there's a science experiment growing in there i'm really turning
into a hickamori uh it's a miracle i don't have bugs in my apartment truly i'm not gonna lie to you
thank god um did you clean the shower i did clean the shower last time the shower is fine the shower
is not bad the nun art i commissioned yeah i commissioned that a while ago um kind of around
that i commissioned that in july um she she had uh um some stuff so i was i was just behind in the
queue and but she was really nice uh she's really wonderful um because literally last second i asked
her if she could change uh my skin tone to be tan and and oh because she sent me the grayscale
and i'm like oh can you make me tan and to add the to add the freckles in the um beauty mark and
she's like oh yeah no problem and now she wants to do like a full body which is really cool and she
like she like there's just she's just the the the talent that the the artist has is like i was
i was just scrolling on vjen and i saw like she does like this ethereal portrait sort of commission
and i saw it and i'm like oh i gotta get one of those like it's so beautiful absolutely gorgeous
um they want to do a full body which is insane um i'm going to pay them anyways because i'm not
going to have them do that for free um and it wasn't expensive either like sometimes like i get like a
really fabulous art from artists and i'm like here have a fat tip because like what um yeah
they were very very cool and i love again i love uh uh catholic catholic imagery like one of my
favorite um statues is i think it's our is it our lady of sorrows
i don't know what it's called
it's like there's a very iconic our lady of sorrows statue
yeah it's i think it's the virgin statues of virgin maria's our lady of sorrows and it's just like
i like that's one of my favorite pieces of all time as well as um that that one painting of lucifer
looking over his arm that's one of my favorite art pieces i have a picture of i need forgot to post
it i have a picture of fia and she looks like uh you know the fallen angel in that because she has
like the expression in her arm is lifted up but i forgot to post it and with those little side by
side of that um but yeah so i but i also wanted to inject some of my witchiness into it with
including baphomet which is a a symbol in most folklor and witchcraft and stuff uh baphomet's
cool lady uh i think and that's who i'm pretty sure that the sucker for love character is
based off of um his baphomet uh but yeah i'm really glad you guys like the piece they even
gave me a little chibi none of me so i'm probably gonna post that um i also really like the art i
just got of me and you guys that i posted the other day uh i made that my discord uh banner and
photo on discord so it's me and my disc like a close-up of me and then eat the i have a harlot
as the the banner and i like it a lot and i made my discord like pink and to go with the hearts and
stuff so that was really i really love that piece and they did that so fast too like i was like oh
because i was gonna put that in the card but marie didn't even end up using it um
and so like they they i asked for like it to be done in like two weeks and they did it like
literally three days later and i was like wow um very nice some really good people on vigen
since i'm not able to use skib fia why are you licking the bed she's just licking her the bed
are you trying to groom yourself but you're just licking the bed
oh lady oh you just moved your leg oh you're moving your legs oh you're stretching your legs
are you trying to hear yeah grab your tail and lick your tail don't don't stop licking me
uh the discord well no there's like we don't have a public discord uh there's a fan made
discord um and then there is the uh what's it called discord for like notifications and stuff
and that's all on the the violer um twitter page you guys can find the links there
elinrin got a patch did it now i'll have to look into that i've also been listening to um
um i've listened up to chapter two of when the goons uh analysis of faith and i really like it so
far i think there's a little bit more of chapter two i gotta listen to but i'm not gonna listen to
chapter three i'll listen to it when i finish the game because i don't want spoilers and stuff but
just um learning more redon got a nerf aw dammit i wish i got to redon before he got nerfed this
is what happened last time because redon got nerfed the first time i played elinrin they patched them
um but uh that's so that's been a really i love i love analysis videos and conspiracy lord stuff
and all that stuff and just kind of deep dives um like the whole like the nun stuff and that was in
there um yeah i hope we get a nun in our in our gen in our gen in our um uh for a concept soon
that'd be really cool gen three gen three nun sick um because i just love like nun stuff
i survived pre-patch redon t-shirts right does johnny tell you what happened to redon in our game
no yeah i want to experience three before the video i do love my lord dives yeah i'll usually
throw on a lore video when i'm trying to work on something because it just helps me focus for
something like when i clean i'll sometimes listen to lord confirmed we ain't getting a nun in gen
tune nun in gen four not in gen three yeah we got sister emmy and you got sister bb you're fine you
got one and you got you got gen one gen two designs go really hard though oh my god
check out with a massive bug really i'll have to look at the fog then most definitely
um you still need to play any bottom release jesus
slime girl nun when i might like uh like it's so i know it's hard it's hard for both me and
shrani not to talk about the gen two stuff um because she's sending me like updates and stuff
and i'm like oh and the artist is oh the raft sheets oh oh she's the so she started with one of my
favorite concepts and i am i love that concept so much she has such a literal name of course
strani loves literal names um i'm happy i got a i got a little bit of hand and helping naming and
stuff but none of them are directly my child sadly gen three i will give i want to give birth to one
of them um should get a dictator style posters of bb oh i like that actually um but yeah hopefully
emi stuff sticks um because you know i want her to be able i don't want her all that work to go to
waste that's their debut yeah gen three's debut will be me giving birth no i think for gen three
i want to ask strani to be like can i have one give me one daughter pretty so i will i will
they will be the most beautiful girl in all the land um i will also give the people what they want
you can also adopt oh no yeah i am adopting all of gen gen two will be you know my little coheis
they will be adorable um but yes pray for emi grab those grab those rosary beads pray
who'll be the father you guys of course that's not even a question
are you gonna do the idea doing a family stream and come back pregnant
maybe that's actually a good idea oh no
hail to the bb we pray for emi um flower cooking but uh yeah so
see you guys uh maybe tomorrow in the twitter space so i clean and kind of get stuff oh hold on
let's check my email to see if i got an email back from the um the place that i applied for the kitty
cat i want blithe
no
at least my panties that i ordered from savages vent here on the way
did you hear back from your therapist i didn't usually she gets back to me i'm gonna wait till
tomorrow and i'm a texture or maybe she did get back to me i didn't see it sometimes her stuff
no she didn't get back to me very weird usually she gets back to me within an hour so i don't know
i hope that um uh no i didn't even hear back about the garage either i have to i have to do
both of those uh i'll follow up on that i wait for it because i don't want to like if she's like
dealing with stuff i don't want to like because um unless she now my therapist is like dealing
with something i don't know because i usually give like kind of like a grace period of like a day
and then i reach out the next day because i don't want to be like oh gotta ask what the ad is today
hi marie i'm not crying don't worry but yeah i don't know why i have this headache um so i'm
gonna go lay down i'm gonna go to sleep um i'm gonna snuggle with fia i'm gonna snuggle with
rena i'm gonna snuggle with boomi uh i'll reach out okay i'll text my therapist um
i don't want to spit yeah i don't want to spam text my there you know what i will texture
because i will i'll probably forget so i'll do it now
and then i'll message my landlord through the resident portal rather through email
because sometimes they don't respond let me do that right now as well
i know i should probably get like an actual menstrual heating pad thing because like
my heating blankets are like i still have the blankets i still see them they're just not
plugged in so i usually accidentally stab myself with the part that plug is supposed to plug into
the plug what's my email redacted redacted at redacted.com
yeah i've been this has like been a really weird period because um i just usually don't get it
for like it's been over a week but it's funny because like my other friends have been telling me
that they have been having their periods for longer than usual so i don't know
okay this website is not working redacted section clip it clip what no no it's good sometimes i need
to push sometimes like because i literally i've been putting stuff off like i'm putting out i've
been putting off doing the dishes i've been putting off cleaning and it's it's not good for me so i
need to maybe yeah maybe let my space well i'll have you guys clean with me can i please get to
the resident portal for the love of god he's all good
okay now let's me can i reply
what on the
what should my budget be
because i have a budget
that's a good portal that matches
my budget should be upon me
yeah a hundred dollars
okay
i'll say 200 is the budget
i have been saving for fias stuff i have quite a bit of money saved so that shouldn't be an issue
i was gonna pay off something but i didn't like uh i can wait i just make the normal payments
so i've been i won't lie to you i've been using that it's the the fanzly money is what
goes towards fias medical
so i'm like i'm hoaring myself out for my daughter
i'm dancing on the pole for my sick child
drunken it for vet bills
so that's what i use that for i literally i have not withdrawn any of the money it's just been
sitting there in my account because i'm not going to touch it unless i need it i haven't even put
it a payout option uh and then like yeah i can literally just like i'm very i'm not shy to talk
about um what my money goes to uh literally usually i can pay my rent thankfully with uh
the the tips from stream elements and then i pay my bills in groceries in like um everything with
patreon um so that's like a car payment car insurance my um what's it called my like electricity
internet and all that stuff home bill how she spent it on crustables a lot and then the rest of the
money i just spend on food and doorkash and then so the stream elements patreon
and then youtube membership i usually set aside for um for taxes i just usually i use i save one
payout for taxes because i don't want to evade taxes i know i do got to cut back the doorkash
um i also have a like an accountant in my family because um my dad used to own a business and my
mom um used to uh needed a personal accountant at one point for her own finances so it's kind of funny
because like i also wouldn't be able to hide what i do from my parents because like my parents are
very close to the accountant and they'll be like you know your daughter has poor money right now i
don't think you would say that um i have to reach out to him speaking of which maybe i'll reach out
to him tomorrow because i would like to get ahead on tax season uh because that is coming up
expeditiously i like to use the word expeditiously um i know i've done meal prepping before um
i have a lot of like throw away top aware stuff to like that i've got for meal prep
and like this is how i like i know like i used to never eat doorkash this much i used to never
so it's really i need to find a better routine i need to start eating better
because i need to um i need to put that freaking chair together as you guys got me it's sitting
in pieces on my porch and then the and then the the cushions are just stuffed in my closet
um
this guy you say yeah oh i'll literally like some of the donothon stuff like um one of the
goals is like me getting a pc and then i know saving to pay off my debt because i ringing up
um a lot of money in credit cards for my pat my personal past health bills from the past few years
um i'm really wishing i never put them on credit cards i wish i just kind of just never paid them
because then usually honestly like they'd never it goes to collections but nobody really does
any like it doesn't affect my credit at all but then if it's on my credit card and my credit card
is maxed out then yeah and then i took out a loan to pay off the credit card and then it got maxed
out again because fia it was me with my health issues and then it was fia because i had to go to
the hospital and i had to get tested i had to do this and that and now it's my sweet girl's turn
the interest pile is up yeah i was able to pay a little bit down but the interest i'd rather just
pay it off in one one foul swoop oh i don't care about collection companies my um one of my
co-workers for my former job um they used to be a tax collector and they said it was the most
horrible job they ever did because uh they had to like shake down an old woman for like
taxes from her dead husband and he's like i can't do that job and i'm like damn brother
Jesus christ um student loans oh good for you i also have student loans to pay but i generally
don't care about those i think i like i didn't finish school i only have like $12,000 in student
loans so it's not that bad and that's i don't really care about those those are those are just
sitting there i don't care about those those i can worry about later um
what interest rate do i have in my card uh i can tell you right now i will literally tell you
how much i have in debt and how much i have an interest i do not give a shit uh a wallet it's
my apple card do do do apple was student stupid enough to give me a seven thousand dollar balance
so i did seven thousand dollars in medical bills seven thousand dollars six hundred seventy two
dollars and three cents and then my interest is and then double that by the way i just say 16k
i count past two i haven't paid it in like two months i don't really care
where is it interest rate card details
it's 27 24 my epr used to be shorter until i got my stuff set up as our goal is 10k
my goal is for four stretch goals oh i said i said really like five thousand dollars because like
i don't you know it's like i'm a big girl it's helpful but i don't i know people
think donathons are a scam um even my dad said so it was funny because i was like oh my birthday
donathons coming up and he's like oh what's that about i'm like well people give me money to do
this this and that and he's like that sounds like a fucking scam and and i just started laughing
really hard seven dollars and 67 cents oh thank you for the don't know i appreciate it
girl put that goal farther how much did i don't remember how much is there i got strawny put
the goal farther she wouldn't let me do that um i don't want to think big because i don't want to
be disappointed and i don't want to set an expectation for people to pay for things for me um
you know like i'm not gonna uh yes i know it's a fucking high ipr um i'm not gonna set an expectation
i'll be like put pressure on you guys to take your hard-earned money to make sure that i get 20
thousand dollars to pay off all my debts like and then you know um i take 20 percent of that uh
velar does i think i think azerka like 15k out of her donathon at the end i don't know um
i assume paul's yeah she did solve the entire yep she did um i know you loved me but i don't
want you to think that to express your love you have to give me monetary things yes you know i know
it's my full-time job and yes like i do appreciate like tips um and that's why i'm like that's why i'm
like please don't you know skip out on patreon because patreon is my primary income so i would
rather people who do patreon than anything else um hi freddy hi everyone in chat um but i like
you know i don't want to put that expectation on you um and like i'm fine like i'm not stressing
like i'm you know i'm taking the right steps i'm doing the right thing i'm talking to the
right people my parents are also advising me um so it's not like i'm not like drowning like i'm
not struggling i'm okay you know and those like things i also need to be more disciplined like
again i'm i will splurge on silly things like um like door dash or like artwork um that's why i
haven't really gone a lot of artwork i did commission a bit of artwork it's only coming out now because
i commissioned it back in july but i i'm not gonna really commission artwork um
and yeah that's just kind of so i just really want to focus on um paying stuff off and getting a new
pc and then 3d it's those are the goals um artwork this is a tax write off yeah i still
don't have to don't know how those work so i have to i have to chat with uh with the accountant
sub to patreon oh thank you yeah i try to have a good handle on things um my parents my mom
was very like my my parents had me when they're like um when they're younger so they made a lot
of stupid decisions with their money and so my mom made sure that i didn't make the same stupid
decisions and i'm also thankful i didn't have those parents that like took out stuff in my name when
i was younger or whatever because i i've had some friends that have like their credit is
absolutely ruined because their parents did that to them um so i'm very thankful my mom is very
my dad's flirt actually no my parents both splurge when they when they really want to um
but they they've been my mom is very smart with her money when she wants to be like again my mom
has been out of a job for a couple months now she she's been looking hard and mind you my mom is
extremely talented woman the job market is just really really bad right now um but my mom like
my parents were still able to go on a little vacation um to the beach and stuff because my mom
saved appropriately and my mom um had made a little nest egg and stuff for emergencies um
my mom got an a in i home economics because of me but yeah so like i try to i try my dad was like
literally hammering down on me he's like don't mess up those freaking taxes she be don't fucking
do it i swear to god he's like it's gonna bite you in the ass i'm not gonna let you do that to
yourself so that's when he put me in touch with the family accountant because he's just like you
need to get this um together i want you to make sure that you're doing everything right um if this
is going to be a long time job for you if you're not making this a hobby if this is going to be your
job uh you have to make sure you go down the right avenues and everything um so even the
scared the IRS exactly uh i had a friend she's a baby his parents open credit yep exactly exactly
my friends have experienced that too so i'm very thankful that my parents didn't do that they never
they never ever did that um yeah my parents came from they were very very poor my parents were very
very poor um my my my parents worked very very very hard to get to me get me um to where i am
and they sacrificed a lot on my behalf so i will and that's why i'm like what i want to do
is like i want to be able to be successful enough that i can do what strani did and buy my parents
a house um because my parents were so happy when they came back from that trip my mom was like wow
i have never been on the beach and living on the beach like that would be the dream and i'm like
i'm just quietly giggling to myself because i'm like you know what one day i'm going to buy you a
beach house oh yeah single single mothers and single fathers they are they are superheroes
if you have a single parent that took uh good care of you then uh you should be make sure make
sure you pay that forward they're very your parents your parent is a superhero uh my freaking allergies
dude yeah um and it sucks because like i know some people don't have parents like that the
second set them up for success um and try to like look out for their best interests so i'm very
thankful for mine um but keep in mind like he doesn't have to be your family you can just rely on
you know they always say they always get the quote we're on uh they always say you know blood is
thicker than water but the it's actually um the blood of the covenant is thicker than the water of
the womb so the the the lasting relationships you make that you bind yourself with other people
they're they're they're tighter bonds they can be tighter bonds than family um and that's why well
some of my uh like i don't have any siblings i don't have any close relatives to me it's literally me
and my parents and then my grandparents and some of my aunts and uncles and i don't i have like cousins
but they're they're they're distant and they're younger um and then i have other cousins that i
just don't talk to anymore and um i know just that you and so like uh so my like i see salam and all
of us my my sisters they are my literal sisters um all of us like a mentor to me so yeah on a different
note did you clear up Australian at the asmr with yama isn't that type no yeah no my mom's not gonna
make smutty asmr with me my dad probably would i would i bet i could try to make my dad read that
i'd be like dad can you read this naughty asmr not like with me because that'd be just be fucking
weird but like like just like can you do like a bfe script my dad totally would though oh my god i'm
so tempted to ask him i'm i'm literally i'm definitely my my mom is too shy my my dad my dad
might my dad would make some fucking sick bfe because my dad has a nice bassy voice you guys
heard it um and he's a very good public speaker although i don't my dad actually might be shy
because he's like what do people recognize my voice from church i'm like if people are watching me
from church they got other issues dad if people who from the church are watching me then um make
more than two percent yeah no i'll i'll if i got any revenue that if my parents made something with
me i would give them all the revenue from said video or said content or any of that i would 100
percent do that for them um you are in for a bit true um is strani seen the script yet
oh that i wrote no i was gonna show her before we streamed let me realize we were like two minutes
over and we were about to start streaming so i was like oh shit let me let me um not do that
dad my fans are craving you uh speaking of which let me find someone to read i'm craving a raid in
like how i said i was gonna end stream my head is still pounding but i just wanted to talk to
you guys before i left uh is strani gonna keep playing let me can somebody actually i can just
go to my her stream myself let me do that right now this is i couldn't keep uh playing
because i was making me motion no this is my stream i just went back to my own fucking stream
nope i keep clicking on my own stream why is it i'm trying to find strani stream and i keep
clicking on my own because we have the same fucking thumbnail okay
you're gonna keep streaming mommy oh i'm in caps lock
you
why don't i come back
I'm sorry if I didn't bark vigorously enough sorry that's Johnny's stream
let's see
let's read Serenity again because of her birthday and she she popped by and say hi so I'll give her
so tell to say happy birthday to Serenity I'm gonna go to sleep
really doing over that I don't know because someone said that they wanted to
join so they could bark but she's reading Maro's right now
yeah are you okay she's like dreaming really hard oh yeah I'll see you guys
tomorrow in a Twitter space we'll clean we'll clean tomorrow together so if you
guys need to get some work done or if you guys need to clean to make sure you
clean with me we're gonna clean we're gonna clean the bathroom we're gonna
clean my floors we're gonna sweep we're gonna vacuum we're gonna do the dishes
we're gonna change the litter those letters need to be changed boomy was
it's been blowing up the litter boxes I ordered more litter so it should be
here and you get better at scooping the litter box I have three different I have
three litter boxes and it's hard to like scoop them all I usually I mostly scoop
the one that I scoop the one that Fia uses most often because I literally have
to put her in it so I'm like I don't you laying in shit and piss dirty dishes
talk space yeah doing your maid yeah I should get a little maid outfit I'm
also the people who have bought me stuff by the way that like outfit wear like
the little cat paw socks in the sweatshirt don't worry I haven't forgotten
about you I've just been I have I want to put those on so I can take some photos
for you guys so don't you worry I'll get to do I'll do that but I just feel like
shit cuz I have my period so I'm just like there I'm all I'm all oh yeah the
shower scrubber is very helpful it came in a couple days after I was ordered I
cleaned the whole bathroom with it the whole tub because I have like wall to
ceiling tile and my water is very late it's like hard water so I'll get like
that pink algae stuff so I have to clean it pretty constantly I put in a filter
on my shower head but I think I have to do a new one because it's starting to
happen again but yeah the hoodie the hoodie is so comfy I also need to buy
new clothes I need to do that I haven't bought any new clothes in years I've
been wearing the same I'm also just like I used to I used to dress up a lot like
I would dress like pretty nice for work and stuff but I don't do that because I
don't go anywhere and so I don't dress as nice so I just been literally living in
t-shirts and panties for the last since June so I maybe I'll get some more
t-shirts and panties maybe I'm wondering if I should be like goth girl fall or
kawaii girl fall because then I'm like then I'll have a focus I'm like what
just said I do I want do I want to be goth or do I want to be kawaii desu I'm
debating maybe I'll have a poll because then if I'm it's if it's goth girl fall
then cuz then I'll just dress super alternatively and I'll take more
pictures why not both no I have to it's weird but I need to focus like I have to
have a focus for my work my outfits oh dear you're so cute she like rolled
onto her back and is showing some belly oh thank you for the belly ma'am goth
kawaii like pastel goth maybe that's just this is pink though that's just kawaii in
my opinion it's more so like do I want to buy more pinks or do I want to buy a
more black clothing for fall you know spooktober yeah yeah let's do a poll
right now actually no I'll do it on my all I'll put the poll on my all just some
more people who aren't watching can see it um Fia can you stop licking your bed
she licks me and then she licks her bed okay it was really nice speaking to you
all again sorry that I know I'm forever like I have such a headache and I'm like
but I want to keep talking to you guys it's so frustrating um I love you guys
very much I hope you have a wonderful rest of your day please don't miss me
too much tomorrow you know we're gonna do that Twitter space and we're gonna clean
I hope you guys you know if you're going through anything that you know cheer up
know that you know you can come and hang out and watch me anytime if you're
having a great day I hope it gets even better okay I love you guys I will see
you around bye I'm also not wait I just took a shower I don't think I'm stinky
nope I smell fine I hope you smell better
probably not to end this stream I almost I didn't I almost just clicked edit video
I'm so stupid okay bye